Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Dolino ist der Drosten macht jetzt nach fünfzig Sendungen Pause. Wir haben jetzt dreihundertfünfzig. Warum machen wir nicht mal Pause?
Weißt du, der Drosten, ne? Kaum hat der fünfzig Sendungen voll, macht der irgendwie Sommerferien, lässt uns hier mit der zweiten Welle alleine. Nicht so wir, ja. Wir äh geben hier weiterhin jeden Tag schlechte Nachrichten.
Lokbuchnetzpolitik Nummer dreihunderteinundfünfzig eure dauerhafte Druckwelle, der eh nicht entkommen könnt von schlechten Nachrichten,
Wir haben immer was parat, was gerade schlechte Laune erzeugen kann. Stimmt's?
Ja, ich ich finde das übrigens sehr bedauerlich, dass der Drosten, also äh weißt du, sowas wie Urlaub hat uns ja hier noch nie von der Arbeit abgehalten.
Unsere Arbeit hier ist unser Urlaub. Ja, das muss man sich mal vorstellen.
Na, ist doch tatsächlich so. Ich.
Ja, da weiß ich nicht. Also wir hatten da auch schon mal eine Sendung irgendwie nicht gemacht im Sommer. Eine.
Ja, gut, aber das war ja dann, äh weil nichts los war. Da wir nichts mehr mitbekommen haben.
Ich habe nix gemerkt.
Nee, finde ich aber trotzdem bedauerlich. Finde ich bedauerlich. Ich bin enttäuscht
Auf einer persönlichen aber auch auf einer professionellen Ebene, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Sehr schön fand ich Drosten hat doch heute äh also,
Er hat ja jetzt offenbar Urlaub oder oder
Ich glaube, der hat gar nicht vollständig oder päda auch gesagt, dass er sich auch mal wieder ein bisschen auf die Forschung konzentrieren möchte und so. Und ähm dann wurde er natürlich, wurde direkt von irgend so einem Bild wicht bemerkt, dass er heute viel twittert.
Und da hat er sich dann direkt mokiert, so hat er etwa nichts besseres zu tun? Und du hast uns Antwort, war einfach nur so, nee, heute nicht. Was ich sehr, sehr gut finde. Und was das aber auch zeigt, ähm das sage ich jetzt mal nur so ganz vorsichtig, ne? Ähm.
Das zeigt einfach nur diese Bildleute, ne, die sind nachtragend. Die merken sich sowas. Die gucken da, weißt du?
Die sitzen da, die die können die pflegen ihren Gräuel und
Gnade dem Drosten, dass der nicht irgendwann mal, weißt du, mit mit einem Flaschenbier im Bauch
äh sich nochmal hinter Steuer setzt oder ähm was weiß ich, vielleicht irgendeine Nebeneinkunft von dem
von dem MDR da jetzt äh falsch versteuert oder so, dann sind das genau diese Wichte, die dann in der ersten Reihe stehen, um den zu demontieren. Und die vergessen nichts. Also die die merken sich die merken wenig.
Aber die vergessen nix. Das sind Elefantengehirne. Und die lauern noch in zwanzig Jahren um den Tod zu trampeln. Und der an solchen Tweets sieht man das.
Ja, die haben auch immer eine eine Tüte Hundescheiße äh in ihrer Hosentasche, damit sie irgendwie im richtigen Moment damit werfen können.
Besser genug Vergleiche aus der aus der Fauna.
Hund, Elefant, Schlange.
Das wird eine tierische Sendung heute hier.
Okay. Äh ja wir ähm ich also.
Bitte Christian Drosten kommt zurück. Lass uns nicht mit den mit der Bildzeitung alleine hier. Wir wir brauchen doch auch so einen den Schutzheiligen, der der Medienopfer.
Du kein Problem, wenn da jetzt so ein Podcast-Loch entstanden ist, dann dann füllen wir das einfach mit LNP und UKW, damit es eigentlich dann auch alles klar, wo es hingeht, ne.
Euer Sommertheater sozusagen. Das sind wir. Sommertheater in der Podcast-Landschaft.
Oh und unser Sommertheater beginnt heute mit Feedback, oder?
Ja, ja, gibt ja genug, ne?
Äh okay, Google freies Android. Ähm ah da äh kann ich bei der Gelegenheit eh nur sagen, das ist eigentlich noch ein ein ein interessantes Phänomen. Äh da wurde ich ähm vom.
ZDF auch zu interviewt. Die haben den Beitrag aber am Ende nicht gesendet, weil äh weil in Stuttgart die Partyszene randaliert hat.
Wo ich mir auch nur so vorstelle, weißt du, wenn ich in Stuttgart Party-Szene wäre, ne? Dann hätte ich auch eine ganze Menge Frustration. Aber das darf man ja so nicht sagen.
Partyszene. Die haben doch da irgendwie paar Jugendliche drangsaliert und irgendwie auf.
Partyszene. Was, ich meine, in Stuttgart ist die Partyszene auch wahrscheinlich in der falschen Stadt, oder? Also wenn ich das versuch, naja, okay.
Ich glaube auch nicht, dass die so groß ist, dass dass damit irgendwie Polizei, Hundertschaften in Betrieb gehalten werden kann. Wenn dem so ist, dann habe ich das vielleicht schon immer verkannt, so oder vielleicht sollten wir da mal die nächste musikalische Revolution in Schwaben irgendwie äh erwarten. Schön wär's.
Ja, es gab ja, es gab doch schon früher auch gute Musik aus aus äh Schwaben.
Ja, was denn?
Ähm kannst du nicht irgendwelche Hip-Hop-Party aus aus Süddeutschland?
Weil's hier so Söhne Mannheims oder was hier unsere Schwurbla.
Was ist denn Punkrock äh irgendwas was gibt's gutes aus Stuttgart? Es gab doch irgendeine.
Was gibt's denn nun mal Gutes aus Stuttgart? Pause? Keine Ahnung. Wir machen's jetzt auf jeden Fall gerade keine Freunde. Es ist schon klar, ne?
Auf jeden Fall könnten die Polizei soll sich da mal wirklich mal ein bisschen ans Lätzchen packen, ne. Also erst drangsalieren sie dann die Leute und dann dann sind sie auf einmal völlig entsetzt. Wenn das irgendwie jemand scheiße findet.
Mann.
Ähm Hip Hop aus Stuttgart. Relativ bekannt gab's doch auf jeden Fall fantastisch vier.
Aus Stuttgart.
Ja, glaube schon.
Mhm. Alle?
Massive Töneskreis und Marz. Fünfundzwanzig Jahre Hip Hop aus Stuttgart. Soll man erstmal was sagen, ja? Also Stuttgart hat eine Partyszene.
Und sie schlägt zurück. Die Party ist die Partyszene. Schlägt zurück.
Äh ja, okay, lasse ich, äh ich hoffe, dass wir einfach dieses Thema äh Stuttgarter Krawall einfach auslassen können. Genauso wie
diese dämliche Tanzkolumne und die noch dämlicheren Reaktionen darauf ähm.
Das ist also da kann man wirklich, das Einzige, was mir dazu einfällt, ne, ist also,
es ist lange her, dass ich ein dermaßen dämlichen Text gelesen habe,
Und es ist bei besonders dämlichen Texten kann man immer darauf.
Kann man immer sicher gehen, dass sich nur noch die Leute darauf zu einer Reaktion genötigt fühlen, die noch dämlicher sind,
Ja, weil sie irgendwie den Eindruck haben, dass sich an dem Text hochziehen könnten. In diesem Fall Reiner Wendt,
und äh unser Innenminister, der dann noch irgendwie großspurig ankündigt, er würde jetzt irgendwie eine Strafanzeige stellen und zwar in seiner Funktion als Innenminister nicht einfach mal in seiner Funktion als Modell Eisenbahner, ja, sondern er muss,
betonen als Innenminister, ja und dann macht das noch nicht mal,
Ja, weil, weil, weil, weil er, weil ihm dann doch noch irgendjemand mit Rest anstand und Sinn gesagt hat, ist eigentlich immer blöd, wenn der Innenminister äh irgendeinen.
Journalisten verklagt ja genau.
Alter Vater, ey, was ist das für wie peinlich? Und dann äh hier Stuttgarter Krawall.
Hast du das mitbekommen? Dann ist er da ja zur zur äh,
Zur Begutachtung gegangen, ja? Und dann haben die so einen zerkratzten und verdelten VW-Bus, der da von der Polizei, der da eben im Rahmen dieser Nacht äh wohl zu Schaden gekommen ist, da extra wieder hingefahren für den Presse.
Oh Mann, ey, das ist also wirklich Trumpismus. Oh, in schlecht. Mhm.
Der ja Alter äh was ist das denn?
Ja, äh.
Also das.
Mir auch nichts mehr zu eingefallen.
Das ist so schwach, ja. Und das war jetzt mal irgendwie eine Woche oder zwei gegen Polizeigewalt demonstriert wurde. Ja, also das ist wirklich ähm.
Herrje, ist das ähm ist das erbärmlich, ja. Also wir sind langsam wieder in der Normalität zurück.
Gut Linus, dass wir uns dazu nicht äußern.
Dass du demen nur Aufregung und Widerspruch und am Ende würden wir noch eine Schelle kassieren, weil wir gesagt haben, es gibt keine Partys in Stuttgart oder da kommt ja noch nicht mal gute Musik her. Dem sind wir gerade nochmal entgangen.
Weißt du, was die Partyszene in Stuttgart hat, was die Partyszene in Berlin nicht hat? Eine Eigentumswohnung in Berlin.
Es reicht.
Feedback. Lass uns, lass uns das Feedback vorlesen, solange es noch in sich im Rahmen hält.
Solange wir, solange wir noch Hörerinnen.
Ja, genau, weiß der Geier, wie die nächste Rolle Feedback aussieht.
Okay, also und übrigens den VW-Bus, ne, für Berliner Verhältnisse, weil eigentlich noch völlig okay. Der ist doch noch gut.
Damit fahren die bei uns noch krumm.
Können wir den haben?
Oh Gott nicht mehr hier. Das vor dem ersten Thema. Oh Mann ey. Ich probier's doch mal. Linus, haben wir eigentlich Feedback bekommen?
Ja, wir haben Feedback bekommen und zwar ähm erstes erstes Feedback Thema Google freies Android.
Hör auf zu lachen.
Das ist.
Das war ein,
mich schon wieder ein.
Innenminister jetzt, dann Brief nach Stuttgart schickt und fragt, ob ich diese Karre haben kann. Das könnte ich noch passieren.
Okay, also Rudolf schreibt uns.
Ich persönlich benutze oder ich weiß immer noch nicht, wie man das ausschreibt, äh ausspricht, also schreiben, weiß ich, ich kann's schreiben, aber nicht sagen. Linage OS ohne probiertäre Google Services. Damit funktioniert die Grundfunktion der App nicht mehr, ja.
Mit anderen Worten die ganze App nicht mehr, ne. Also wenn's Code-Funktion nicht funktioniert, ist immer schlecht,
Welche technischen Voraussetzungen werden benötigt, damit die App auch ohne Google-Services läuft, wäre das auf App-Seite zu lösen oder auf US-Seite. Vielen Dank schon mal für eure Einschätzung.
Und ähm da ebenso wurde ähm,
von Pierre kommentiert als über Google freie Geräte geredet wurde, ist mir aufgefallen, dass du Micro Gene nicht zu kennen scheinst. Das ist eine freie Alternative zu den Google Play Services
man kann damit auch den Playstore nutzen und so manch andere APIs, ihr auch manuell X Punkt ORG.
Die Corona-App kann man damit natürlich nicht nutzen. So, ähm der Punkt ist,
Es muss jetzt erst außerhalb der Google Play Dienste diese Grundfunktion in das Betriebssystem kommen. Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe beabsichtigt,
Google ja sogar, diese Grundfunktion auch mal in das Betriebssystem mit aufzunehmen, hat aber zunächst für den schnellen Roller auf diese Play Services gesetzt
Tim, ist das? Habe ich das richtig verstanden.
Das wird so vermutet, dass äh es hieß ja immer, wird irgendwie ins Betriebssystem integriert. Das mag für Google dann genau das bedeuten, weil Apple
Ist es in dem Sinne eigentlich schon im Betriebssystem, von daher weiß ich immer noch nicht so richtig, was das eigentlich genau heißen soll.
Andererseits ist diese Grundfunktion ja auch nicht so schwer, so dass wir ähm da hier erstens in den in dem Report-Sutorial zu der Corona-Warn-App Android schon die Diskussion sehen und hier ein Gitterprojekt,
sehen. Äh ich weiß, es sieht noch nicht so aus, als hätte das allzu viel,
Komits, ah doch, Kora, lieber Android, da ist schon einiges entstanden. Dieses Versuchen.
Diese API wohl nachzubauen, um da quasi den Teil, den App, den Google jetzt nicht open Source hat, den irgendwo anders mit,
Also den auch in die Nicht-Google-basierten-Geräte mit hineinzuzerren und genau das wäre etwas gewesen, was Google ganz stark erleichtert.
Wenn sie ihren Kram Open Source gemacht hätten. Und das ist ja auch das, was wir in der letzten ähm Sendung auch klar nochmal nachdrücklich gefordert haben. Aber jetzt arbeitet eben die Community dran, auch das eine,
eine positive Folge von diesem ganzen aber eine unnötige Folge der Entscheidung, die äh Google hier getroffen hat, das irgendwie nicht zu veröffentlichen.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, der Mark ist jetzt viele äh Gründe gegeben haben, insbesondere auch die Kurzfristigkeit des ganzen Vorhabens und dann äh ist ja auch damit zu rechnen, dass,
sich dieses Projekt auch noch oder diese Spezifikation noch sehr schnell ändern wird,
Na ja, wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall ist es so und äh hat ja auch eine eigene Implementierung. Ist jetzt auch nicht so, dass jetzt diese Funktionalität, dieses Frameworks
so mega komplex wär. Also da ist ja nun auch nicht so viel zu tun. Und ähm.
Na ja, aber das muss ins Betriebssystem rein. Also ich, ich bleibe dabei, als hätte man das äh es gibt keinen Grund, dass oder es gibt es ist auf jeden Fall von Nachteil das nicht, Open Source zu machen und die, das wollte ich ja gerade sagen, bevor ich nochmal hier an die mich an Stuttgart erinnern musste.
Ähm wenn man sich die Download-Zeilen anschaut, siehst du ungefähr eine Gleichverteilung zwischen Android und.
IOS. Und jetzt stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wie kommt es, weil du eigentlich, so vorsichtig eine Marktaufteilung von fünfundsiebzig zu zwanzig Prozent hast, zwischen den beiden äh Betriebssystemen.
Ähm im Smartphonemarkt. Das heißt, man würde.
Eigentlich, wenn die, wenn die Art des Betriebssystems keine Rolle spielen würde, erwarten, dass man ungefähr,
zwei, dreimal mehr Android Installts sieht als iOS in Stores. Das ist aber nicht der Fall. Und jetzt äh stellt sich natürlich die Frage, woher kommt das, ne? Jetzt könnte es sein, dass ähm viele der Android-Geräte da draußen sagen, vielleicht ähm,
Geräte sind, die keine Updates mehr bekommen, die vielleicht auch so alt sind, dass sie schon gar keine Play Services haben. Es könnte sein, dass,
insbesondere die Menschen, die sage ich mal, an dem Smart Teil ihres Smartphones kein besonderes Interesse haben.
Diese Android-Geräte kaufen und dann nirgendwo irgendwie registriert sind mit ihr, also auch für Google Play Services musst du dich ja quasi registrieren, wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe. Ähm das das kann alles sein. Ist auf jeden Fall ein.
Ähm auffälliger und noch nicht abschließend erklärter ähm Umstand, dass hier scheinbar.
Die Verbreitung auf Android nicht so zügig geht wie wie auf Apple.
Auch von der anderen Seite her betrachten. Das kann auch viel mit mit Apple und seiner Kundschaft zu tun haben. Da ist einfach.
Es könnte auch ein Kundschaftseffekt sein, ja, ist richtig, aber das glaube ich nämlich eigentlich nicht, weil prinzipiell man zumindest von den vom Virtual-Signal.
Sage ich mal, richtet sich iOS schon sehr stark sehr viel stärker an Privatsphäre,
affine Leute. Hast du jetzt gerade wieder gesehen, ne, die bauen irgendwelche Anti-Tracking-Maßnahmen ins Betriebssystem ein, die zelebrieren öffentliche Diskussionen mit dem FBI über den Zugang zu Geräten, ähm
verfolgen, was man ja auch an den Gerätepreisen sieht, eine andere ein anderes Geschäftsmodell als Google, das eben hauptsächlich,
über diese Daten agieren möchte so und.
Wenn das der ausschlaggebende Faktor wäre, dann könnte man von den Apple-Leuten eigentlich auch erwarten, dass sie sagen, nee, ich ich installiere so eine App nicht.
Ich glaube also eher, dass es an der Diversität des Ökosystems liegt.
Das ist aber nicht das, was ich meinte, ne, sondern es meinte einfach, dass ähm da einfach eine höhere Bereitschaft ist, überhaupt mit Apps zu arbeiten. Das ist äh einfach.
Kulturelles Ding. Also man ist da so early ay top da und äh schnell dabei und das das,
erklärt vielleicht nicht alles. Ich bin nur so partiell überrascht davon.
Ich bin, ich kann's auf jeden Fall nicht vollständig erklären. Ich bin gespannt, wann äh Fernseher bestimmt noch herausfinden.
Ja und zumal äh man ja auch äh abwarten muss. Also Downloads heißt ja nicht, ist im Betrieb, ne? Also Download kann auch nur heißen, wurde mal runtergeladen,
und äh wie viele Installationen tatsächlich laufen werden, das ist eine Statistik, auf die ich noch ganz gespannt bin.
Dann das,
Paypal von verschiedenen Wissenschaftlerinnen und Forschern zu dem Google Apple Protokoll. Dazu kommentiert Vanessa in einem sehr langen Kommentar, den ich jetzt nicht vollständig ähm
vorlesen kann. In einem Punkt bin ich nicht ganz einer Meinung mit euch und das ist das Mind The Gap Paper. Ich verstehe sehr gut, dass wir kein Wissenschaftlerinnenbashing machen wollte. Trotzdem wollte ich das,
nicht so stehen lassen und versuche mich mal an einem leinhaften Review. Was mir an diesem nicht gefällt, ist sowohl die Vermarktung.
Als auch der Stil. Von einem wissenschaftlichen Paper erwarte ich objektivität, die in der Regel ergebnisoffene Beantwortung einer Fragestellung
und dass Behauptungen,
bewiesen oder zumindest belegt werden. Das meinte Gap Paper verfolgt meinem Eindruck nach eine sehr klare Zielsetzung, nämlich die Schnittstelle von Google und Apple als massiv unsicher und datenschutzfeindlich darzustellen. Dazu werden an vielen Stellen unbelegte und nur sehr schlecht begründete,
Tatsachen aneinandergereiht. Dann kommt ein wirklich sehr lang, sehr genau,
und denke ich sehr zutreffende Analyse verschiedener Äußerungen im Paper.
Und Vanessa kommt zu dem Schluss. Insgesamt kann ich nur sagen, für mich ist das leider keine wichtige akademische Arbeit, sondern viel heiße Luft, um ein recht dürftiges Resultat. Ähm.
Blubb, auf den den oder die Vanessa sich auch bezog, sagt ähm.
Das PDF ist soweit ich weiß nirgends akzeptiert. Es geht also nicht darum, ein Paper vor der Konferenz oder der Publikation in einem Journal,
zur Verfügung zu stellen, fragt sich also.
Warum das kurz vor dem Release der Corona-Warnapp unbedingt raus musste? Ist das Thema wirklich so wichtig für die Informatik? Ich denke nicht,
Aber na gut, kann man machen. Die mit dem PDF verbundene Berichterstattung ist aber nicht ganz ungewollt. Die TU titelt,
Corona-Warnapps haben Defizite bei Sicherheit und Datenschutz.
Ähm und mal einen Blogbeitrag davor schauen. Oha, eine eigene Corona-App ist die beste der Welt. Und mit ihrem Alter Ego treiben die Autoren, die unglückliche Berichterstattung selbst aktiv voran über Twitter. Ähm.
Journalisten, die das ähnlich wie ihr einordnen, wird explizit widersprochen. So, ähm,
Das denke ich sind alles einfach mal gute Beobachtungen und ähm ja, man hat herausgehört, dass wir.
Oder zumindest ich hier vorsichtig war, den Forschenden äh mit den Forschenden hart ins Gericht zu gehen. Ähm,
Interessanterweise haben sich gleich zwei Autoren des Papers bei mir gemeldet und ähm,
sinngemäß äh gesagt so, danke für die Einordnung. Und ähm,
dazu bleibt mir jetzt nur zu kommentieren. Dieses Paper hat ja viele Autorinnen und Autoren,
Und ähm ich ich rieche da oder ich äh es klingt so ein bisschen raus, dass es vielleicht in dieser Forschungsgruppe unterschiedliche.
Auffassung darüber gibt, wie die Ergebnisse zu interpretieren sind
Also ähm einer der Autoren hat mir geschrieben, ich möchte dir für die Einordnung von unserem in Logbuch Netzpolitik und anderen Medien danken, die unter
suchten Angriffe wurden bereits in der Literatur theoretisch vorgestellt. Unsere Intention war es, darauf hinzuweisen, dass sie prinzipiell auch praktisch funktionieren könnten.
Wir arbeiten gerade an einer Darstellung des Aufwands und nutzen's dieser Angriffe sowie potentieller Gegenmaßnahmen, um die von dir angesprochene tatsächliche Relevanz, beziehungsweise Wahrscheinlichkeit der Angriffe in der Realität auch im Report selbst klarzumachen,
Also der Autor äh geht hier äh begegnet im Prinzip genau dem Kritikpunkt, den auch Vanessa.
Sehr ausführlich begründet darstellen konnte.
Für praktische Experimente mit der Exposur Notification IPA fehlt uns aber die Möglichkeit, die tatsächliche Implementierung der Schnittstelle aufgrund der von Google und Appli,
vergebenen Berechtigungen zu untersuchen. Positiv dabei ist, dass die Angriffsfläche dadurch prinzipiell verringert wird, negativ ist, dass der Code der Exporte Notification EPA weder nachvollziehbar noch testbar ist, sowohl,
obwohl das Projekt ja eigentlich unter Open Source firmiert. Das ist also jetzt hier, bezieht sich auf den.
Punkt, dass man nicht ohne Weiteres eine selbstgebaute,
auf sein Handy deployen kann, die dann auch wirklich auf das Exposur Notification API zugreifen kann. Das ist auch ähm.
Aus ein weiteres, ein weiteres Problem fällt. Das hatten wir, glaube ich, auch in der letzten Sendung angesprochen, dass hier das Betriebssystem den Zugriff auf diese API unterbindet, ist also eine Private API.
Was einerseits der
Für die Forschung problematisch ist, andererseits eben auch verhindert, dass jetzt jeder sagt, hier übrigens, wir haben die Corona-Warnapp äh mal gebaut. Nimm doch meine Version. Da hast du noch einen lustigen Helik Hello Kitty dabei oder so, ne? Das ähm
und vielleicht noch fünf. Das wird dann also verhindert.
Das ist schwierig äh ja, also.
Ich denke, das ist kompliziertes Feld. Es gab auch mehrere, die sich in den Kommentaren ähm,
unterschiedlicher Schwere darüber beklagt haben, dass die App nicht wirklich reproduzierbar zu bauen ist. Ähm.
Das ist einer der Prüfsteine des CCC.
Und ähm also um das jetzt mal verleihen, zu erklären, man hat den Quelltext, ne, man hat eine Anleitung, wie man aus diesem Quelltext eine fertige App macht, ja, das,
Bedeutet, das kompilieren und wenn ich diesen Befehl ausführe, ist es tatsächlich,
in vielen Fällen so oder eigentlich man kann sagen der Standardfall ist, dass sich da immer was anderes rauskriege. Ja, also zweimal eine App komplizieren, führt in winzigen Abweichungen.
In sehr vielen Fällen immer zu einem anderen Ergebnis. Weil es weil irgendwelche
äh mit in den
ähm in die App hineinkommen, weil bestimmte Prozesse, die beim Kompilieren stattfinden, tatsächlich keine oder beim Zusammenbauen stattfinden, nicht einhundert Prozent die terministisch sind. Und es ist eine eigene seit längerer Zeit,
vor vorangetriebene Wissenschaft dafür zu sorgen, dass Bilz quasi,
reproduzierbar sind. Also wenn man den Bildprozess durchführt, dass der Bitt genau zu dem gleichen Ergebnis führt, dass es bei dieser App nicht der Fall.
Und da wittern jetzt und ist aber bei bei wahrscheinlich dem der überwiegenden.
Bei überwiegenden Menge von Software der Fall, dass das leider nicht so ist
und ähm da da kommen da jetzt auch welche und sagen, ja, dann weiß ich ja gar nicht, ob die Corona-Warn-App, die im Playstore äh oder die jetzt irgendwie über Google und Apple kommt, die ist, die ich auf meiner, auf meinem Gerät habe.
Ja, das stimmt, aber auch das würde ich dann in dem Bereich der akademischen Auseinandersetzungen.
Begeben, ja und nicht unbedingt sagen, dass jetzt.
Von einem erhöhten Risiko auszugehen ist, als bei jeder anderen App, die du irgendwo kriegst und bei den vielen Apps, die noch nicht mal Open Source sind, dass dir jetzt hier jemand einen anderen Quelltext untermogelt, als der, der bei Gitter zu sehen ist. Wenn das der Fall ist, ja.
Dann kann Wirecard sich freuen, weil sie nicht mehr der größte Skandal äh zwanzig zwanzig in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland.
Hm, na ja, ich denke auch, dass es da gibt es einfach auch eine Menge öffentliche Kontrolle jetzt in diesem Zusammenhang, dass ich das jetzt nicht als
primäres Problem machen sollte. So oder so diese Technologie, diese Erstrebenswerte Technologie von Bills stößt natürlich an vielen Stellen
auch so Probleme ein paar hast du jetzt schon benannt, da mit den Tims also schon, wenn man das baut, ist es irgendwie jedes Mal anders. Aber selbst, wenn das immer identisch wäre, hast du ja mittlerweile auch so die Delivery über die App Stores, die zum Beispiel bei Apple eben so sind, dass dann eben auch noch vom Telefon selber, beim Download, Optimierung auf den jeweiligen Prozessor,
et cetera und das kann den Prozess ganz an der Stelle ohnehin nicht abgreifen, selbst wenn das nicht passieren würde, also das ähm.
Es ist nicht so einfach. Wenn es, wenn es einfach wäre, äh dann hätten wir nicht seit seit Jahren eben diese Initiative. Wir haben ja vor ein paar Jahren auch schon auf dem Kongress ähm eingeladen.
Ähm die dot org, ähm die sich die,
Das ist eine, da muss da muss sich in der ganzen Informatik und im Programmierwesen viel tun, um um das zu erreichen, ne. Das ist also nicht irgendwie sowas wie ähm hast du jetzt den Reproducible Build Fleck im Comppila angemacht oder nicht, ne,
Okay, also äh das nur am Rande. Es gab da noch, da fällt mir ein auf Twitter noch so die Frage, naja, wenn warum macht man jetzt eigentlich eine Single Purpos-App,
und nicht ähm direkt die Pandemie-App.
Für alles was Pandemie ist. Ähm das ist ein ganz entscheidender Punkt. Das hatten wir hier in der Sendung vor einigen Monaten auch schon besprochen. Wenn man so etwas baut, dann muss ganz klar sein, welchem Zweck das dient,
und zukünftige Änderungen dieser App müssen diesen Zweck auch weiterhin unterliegen und das ist tatsächlich eine sehr,
wichtige und sinnvolle Anforderungen zu sagen, die Corona-Warn-App wird jetzt nicht nächste Woche umgetauft in die in die Grippe, Mums Masern rödeln
und äh Partyszene Stuttgart-Warn-App. Ja, das ist äh,
das ist ein ein ganz grundsätzlicher Anspruch, dass man solche besonderen Maßnahmen und besonderen Apps zu besonderen,
Anlässen und zu besonderen Zwecken schafft und diese Zwecke müssen immer klar bestimmt sein und ähm das ist ganz sinnvoll, das hier für,
auf diese spezifische Covid-Neunzehn-Pandemie zu beschränken.
Und auch an der Stelle, ne, ist halt wieder Betriebssystemkontrolle über so ein Framework,
ein positiver Faktor, weil wenn Apple und Google sich dann einig sind so, okay, Pandemie ist vorbei, brauchen wir nicht mehr,
dann schalten die das einfach mal aus und dann ist egal, was du da für eine App öfter am Telefon hast, dann existiert diese Funktionalität einfach nicht mehr von heute auf morgen.
Wir haben übrigens dieses Paper auch noch äh bei UKW nochmal besprochen, noch ein paar andere Sachen moniert, die äh uns da nicht gefallen haben über das, was wir jetzt hier äh besprochen hatten, hinaus. Wer also Lust hat, sich da in dieser Diskussion noch weiter zu beteiligen kann.
Dann auch nochmal reinhören.
So, dann kommentiert Bernd. Ähm zu der Auseinandersetzung, die Tim und ich halten, wie wir möglichst den Gästeblock in Quarantäne schicken können und ähm,
vielleicht auch noch ein paar Spieler, aber ähm okay, Bernd
Ich arbeite in der Veranstaltungsbranche und bin aktuell Teil einer Arbeitsgruppe, die sich mit der Fragestellung auseinandersetzt, wie im Herbst unter Einhaltung der Corona-Regeln wieder Veranstaltungen stattfinden können,
und was das für den Veranstaltungsbetrieb bedeutet. In diesem Zusammenhang wurde auch über die Corona-App und andere Möglichkeiten der Nachverfolgung von,
Kontakten gesprochen,
Es wird von Seiten der genehmigenden Behörden in jedem Fall eine Anforderung an Veranstalter geben, dass auf der Veranstaltung ein Kontect-Tracing möglich sein muss und,
Veranstalter dazu, wie auch im Restaurant, die Daten der Teilnehmer vorhält.
Das mag bei einer Einzelveranstaltung wie einem Konzert sogar noch relativ gut über zu lösen sein. Wie allerdings,
soll das auf einer Veranstaltung, die in mehreren Spielstätten über mehrere Tage stattfindet.
Gelöst werden. Auch da hätte man natürlich die Möglichkeit zu sagen, wir machen das beim Betreten des Veranstaltungsgeländes mit Zettel und im Zweifel bekommt die Behörde,
halt einfach alle. Man könnte die Teilnehmer aber auch bei der Teilnahme,
an jedem Vortragsseminar Bereich der Veranstaltung so ein Zettel ausfüllen lassen, um ein genaueres Tracing zu ermöglichen. Beide Varianten erscheinen mir weder besonders praktikabel noch besonders datensparsam.
Würde man in diesem Szenario einen Veranstalter haben, der sich sehr für das Verhalten seiner Teilnehmer interessiert, ließen sich aus so einer Zettelflut mit ein bisschen Fleißarbeit sehr schnell Profile über die Teilnehmer und ihre Interessen anlegen,
Klammer auf, kurze Anmerkung von mir. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das ganze Menge an Veranstalter auch tatsächlich interessieren würde.
Ähm weiter Bernd, auch wenn man so ein System zerlöst, droht ähnliches klar. In meiner Wahrnehmung wäre die vermutlich einfachste Lösung
zur Nachverfolgung benötigten Daten beim ersten Zutritt zum Veranstaltungsgelände einlösen des Tickets einmal aufzunehmen und alle Teilnehmer zu verpflichten. Die Corona-Warn-App,
installiert und aktiviert auf dem Telefon zu haben. So schützt man die Teilnehmer der Veranstaltung vor der Neugier kommerzieller Akteure im Veranstaltungsbereich,
und muss im Zweifel nicht mehrere zehntausend Menschen waren, weil eine Person die Veranstaltung besucht hat.
Und dann positiv getestet wurde. Ich würde mich sehr darüber freuen, eure Gedanken dazu zu hören. Vielen Dank für die gute Arbeit mit eurem Podcast.
Also.
Wir hatten ja das geht ja nochmal an das Thema, was wir in der letzten Sendung schon angesprochen haben zurück jetzt besonders spannend ist natürlich hier die Situation, eine Veranstaltung mit mehreren Spielstätten. Ja ähm,
Ich denke, eine Verpflichtung zur Nutzung dieser App wird einfach nicht möglich sein. Ähm.
Und sollte auch nicht möglich sein. Ähm auch wenn.
Bernd, an dieser Stelle schon sehr gut darstellst, dass das wahrscheinlich die beste Lösung wäre. Ja? Die beste Lösung.
Häufig aber eben ein theoretisches Konzept, was an der Realität.
Scheitert und auch hier wäre ja der Punkt ähm eine,
wenn man das täte, ja, dann geh, dann geht den Leuten vielleicht der Akku alle. Was machst du dann? Fliegen die dann von der Veranstaltung oder ne, kriegen die Ärger mit der Polizei, wenn wenn ihr Akku alle ist, oder, oder, oder. Ähm.
Ich denke tatsächlich, dass hier vielleicht, vielleicht jetzt mal.
Ins Blaue überlegt, dann doch solche ähm Hardwarelösungen interessant werden können. Es gibt ja eine ganze Reihe Unternehmen, die quasi so kleine Schlüsselanhängerchen da irgendwie bauen,
ja? Ähm die.
Contact tracing ermöglichen sollen. Und leider aber in geschlossenen Systemen fungieren, ne. Vielleicht wäre das eine Möglichkeit, im Veranstaltungsbereich zu sagen,
dir gehört so ein kleiner ähm,
dir gehört so ein kleiner Schlüsselanhänger, der zu den zu nutzen, du dann eben verpflichtet bist. Der ist aber dann eben vollständig anonym und der hat ein separates Alarm Alarmierungssystem, ja, um quasi nicht die Menschen zur,
nutzt zum Besitz eines bestimmten Smartphones und zur Installation einer App zu zwingen. Ähm.
Ich weiß auch ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie das, wie das rechtlich ist. Ich glaube tatsächlich, dass das eben eine Grauzone ist, weil
es eben nicht verhindert würde, dass ein Veranstalter das tatsächlich täte. Ähm das Einzige, was das wahrscheinlich im Moment verhindert, dessen Veranstalter oder eine Veranstaltungs,
Gesellschaft so etwas tut, ist der riesige Shitstorm, den sie sich im Zweifelsfall damit eintreten würde. Und deswegen,
Ich denke, man muss sich von dieser Idee zur Nutzung dieser App Menschen zu verpflichten.
Verabschieden und gerade du hast jetzt hier so, ne, eine Spielstätte mit mehreren Orten und so, ne, zehntausend Besuchende, da, ja, kommen einem ja bestimmte Veranstaltungen in den Sinnen, die es so gibt, äh wo es dann vielleicht viele Vortragsseele oder sowas gibt, ne.
Da bewegen sich ja dann trotzdem Menschen durch und ich glaube nicht,
dass egal, wie genau dein Contect-Tracing ist, du am Ende sagen könntest, von diesen zehntausend Personen.
Hatten jetzt aber nur,
zweihundertfünfzig Kontakt zu der infizierten Person. Deswegen alarmieren wir nur diese zweihundertfünfzig. Weil wenn wir davon ausgehen, dass diese Veranstaltung jetzt ähm so und so viele Tage geht, dann könnten ja diese,
zweihundertfünfzig ihrerseits auch wieder Viruslast weiter getragen haben auf andere. Das heißt, du hättest dann eben die zweite und die dritte Ebene des Kontaktes und.
Deswegen glaube ich, dass das nicht funktionieren würde am Ende nicht alle zehntausend Besuchenden tatsächlich zu alarmieren.
Dazu kommt ja auch noch, dass wir uns an einem Punkt,
befinden, wo jetzt die Wirksamkeit dieser Maßnahme ohnehin noch ein bisschen in den Sternen steht, ne. Was ja auch die
und dieses ganze,
Apple Google Framework versuchen abzubilden ist ja dieses ähm man hat halt für so und so lange äh sehr nah beieinander gestanden und das ist ja auch noch alles extrem davon geprägt
ähm von dieser Grundidee der Tröpfcheninfektion, ne? Während man ja mittlerweile auch sehr viel über Sohle und äh entsprechende Luftzustände in größeren Räumen auch äh spricht. Und wir da mit der Forschung noch gar nicht so an dem Punkt sind
ne und wie du schon richtig sagtest, ähm,
auch der hohe Maß das hohe Maß an Freiwilligkeit macht's schwierig. Wir haben hier einfach jetzt einen Konflikt und der Konflikt ist, wir haben es mit einer gesundheitlichen Bedrohung zu tun, die alle umfasst.
Und die deren Gegenmaßnahmen, die uns derzeit so einfallen, technische Gegenmaßnahmen gegen.
Ein paar Prinzipien verstoßen, die wir eigentlich äh sehr zu schätzen wissen,
So und und das ist das ist der Konflikt hier und der der lässt sich wirklich nicht ohne weiteres auflösen. Gut, der Kommentar war ja jetzt,
Keine generelle Diskussion, sondern der nachvollziehbare Konflikt der Veranstaltungsbranche in irgendeiner Form, was unternehmen zu können, was ausreichend akzeptabel ist für Gesundheitsämter und vor allem natürlich auch für die Teilnehmer einer Veranstaltung.
Da jetzt die technische Lösung schon gefunden ist, weiß ich nicht. Es könnte mir vorstellen, dass es halt auf der Grundidee, wie wir das jetzt grade versuchen, für alle äh zu machen, durchaus so mit so dedizierten Geräten, wie du das gerade angesprochen hast, dass man da,
interessanten Lösungen kommen muss. Das wäre auch etwas, wo alle Security-Forscher und,
Nicht nur Security, also auch Entwickler generell, die sich jetzt an dieser Diskussion beteiligt haben, äh überlegen müssen, wie wie man das eben äh auch noch darstellen kann, dass man eben mit so,
anonym Begegnungswolken auf einer Veranstaltung äh in irgendeiner Form äh eine Möglichkeit schafft, hier äh eine Benachrichtigung im Nachgang zu einer Veranstaltung,
zu realisieren in irgendeiner Form. Das wäre interessant, ja? Hm, habe ich jetzt bisher noch nichts gesehen und.
Bis dahin kann man einfach nur sagen, es bleibt schwierig.
Okay, dann Nico. Er hat das geschrieben, ich finde es sehr gut, dass er nochmal fast eine ganze Folge zu
zu den FAQ zur Corona-App gemacht habt. Allerdings ist es schade, dass die meisten Leute
die sich ebenfalls diese Fragen stellen werden, vermutlich nicht die Motivation haben, werden zu suchen, bis sie euren Podcast finden. Stattdessen werden wohl viele aufgrund ihrer Bedenken, die App einfach nicht installieren. Eigentlich müsste
im öffentlich rechtlichen Fernsehen jetzt nochmal eine Sondersendung zu Primetime mit einer verständlichen, ausführlichen und neutralen Erklärung der App gesendet werden, dann würden die öffentlich-rechtlichen endlich mal ihren Bildungsauftrag gerecht werden. Ähm
Ja, jetzt ist die Frage, es gibt ja auch natürlich ein paar Leute, die sich wahrscheinlich von einer solchen Sendung im öffentlich-rechtlichen, nicht unbedingt überzeugen lassen würden. Ähm,
Es gibt aber tatsächlich auch.
Derartige Sendung, ne, also es zum Beispiel wurde ich relativ lang im ARD Hauptstadtstudio von Christian Fuchs zu diesen Release interviewt und das wurde,
über deren Social Media Kanäle vertrieben. Ja, also wo man jetzt vielleicht ähm in die,
in bestimmte Regionen kommt, die vielleicht auch nicht einfach abends abendfüllende Sendungen im ähm im öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehen schauen oder so.
Ähm ansonsten, ne, man kann ja diesen Podcast empfehlen, einige tun das und da freuen wir uns natürlich auch immer drüber.
Ja, also ich meine, wenn die, wenn die App so viel Downloads hat, dann kann sich das durchaus auch gerne auf diesen Podcast übertragen.
App könnte eigentlich auch ergänzt werden, so ein Lockbuch. Sie haben zwar kein Corona, gute Nachricht, aber eine neue Folge Logbuch ist draußen, ja, vielleicht müssen wir da mal.
Ja, einfach gleich ein Podcast-Player da noch mit einbauen. Warum sind wir da noch nicht drauf?
Aber nur für Lokbuch Netzpolitik
Ich denke, wir haben ja jetzt einen Gut bei äh bei SAP und Deutsche Telekom. Insofern werde ich da mal ein Fest, ähm nee, ein Echo, Echo, das können die ja machen. Also ich ich denke ja bei dem, bei dem, was die App gekostet hat, haben die ja vielleicht nur einen oder anderen Personentag über,
um das.
Ja musst du noch UKW reinmachen, dann bin ich dabei.
Okay, das können wir, können wir machen. Ähm womit wir dann jetzt auch bei dann doch einigen.
Problemen mit dieser App ähm sind, die sich jetzt nach den äh nach der ersten, wo ist das jetzt eine Woche gewesen, ja ne, knappe Woche.
Mhm. Woche ist.
Genau eine Woche. Ja, ungefähr vor einer, also heute ist Mittwoch und Dienstag, letzte Woche wurde sie ja, glaube ich, releast, ja? Ähm.
Jetzt läuft sie, aber es gibt äh ist jetzt vielleicht muss man vor vorsichtig vorher sagen, bei einem solchen.
Projekt ist es zu erwarten, dass es auch zu Problemen kommt.
Bei jeder Software ist es zu erwarten.
Genau, ich hatte ja irgendwann mal auch gesagt, das ist ein Mammutprojekt, was in dem Ausmaß.
Weder in der Zeit noch in dem Umfang äh so jetzt irgendwie jemals realisiert wurde. Das nur vorweg und jetzt äh ist aber auch die Schonfrist vorbei. Deswegen gehen wir mal an die Probleme.
Ja, wie sieht's denn überhaupt aus? Also wir haben zwölf Komma sechs Millionen Downloads. Das ist zumindest die vom RKI
veröffentlichte Zahl, wie vorhin schon erwähnt, es wird kolportiert, dass die gut die Hälfte davon auf iOS Nutzer zurückzuführen ist
Gut, das nehmen wir jetzt einfach mal so zur Kenntnis und bewerten das nicht weiter. Ähm was man jetzt sehen kann, ist also erstmal gab's ja einen relativ starken
Schub am Anfang, also es wurde in den ersten Tagen von sehr vielen Leuten runtergeladen und jetzt sind wir so bei ungefähr vierhunderttausend Installationen pro Tag
muss immer noch ganz okay ist. So, also wenn das jetzt so anhielte, wovon ich unbedingt auszugehen ist, dann.
Dann dann ist es äh ein sehr großer Erfolg. Trotz alledem glaube so zwölf Komma sechs Millionen hat jetzt nicht unbedingt jeder vorausgesagt.
Ne? Kann man nicht äh sagen.
Enorm über die Erwartungen hinaus, ne? Ich meine, Frankreich hat's nicht über, hat's jetzt irgendwie nicht über sechshunderttausend geschafft.
Genau und vor allem, wenn wir das mal äh auch mal umrechnet auf die Bevölkerung, also äh ich habe mal kurz geguckt, wenn man ähm mal schaut, wie viel in Deutschland so fünfzehn oder älter,
sind oder was sechzehn oder älter, also sozusagen ab Jugendliche
Ähm dann bedeutet diese Zahl ungefähr so fünfzehn Prozent der Bevölkerung.
Es ist schon, das ist schon massiv. Das ist schon irre, so viele Verbreitungen zu erlangen. Ne, das kriegst du normalerweise in.
Wir wissen nicht, ne, wir wissen nicht,
runtergeladen, um es dann gleich wieder zu löschen. Das ähm ist, glaube ich, eine Information, die das RKI an der Stelle nicht da mit reinreflektiert. Äh wir müssen auch
abwarten, ob diese Zahl von laufenden Installationen auch wirklich nochmal signalisiert werden wird, das ließe sich im Prinzip schon hochrechnen, also zumindest kann man ja sehen, welche Aktivität auf diesen Downloadserver ist, wenn halt jede App einmal pro Tag da vorbei
dann weiß man halt, wie viele eben aktiv sind. Ähm,
hoffe ich ohnehin auf so eine Art Dashboard, wo man vielleicht auch mal generell sieht, wie viele Meldungen gab's denn nun wirklich dadrüber, et cetera, das sind ja alles äh relativ einfach und unproblematisch zu erfassende Informationen.
Nichtsdestotrotz gab's Probleme und zwar ähm gab es Verzögerungen bei der Veröffentlichung der ersten tatsächlich mit dieser App durchgeführten,
Meldung. Das wurde im Prinzip am Wochenende schon klar, weil aufgrund dieser hohen Download-Zahlen,
Könnte man ja einfach mit ein bisschen Wahrscheinlichkeitsrechnung dahergehen, sich anschauen, aha, wie viel Meldungen hatten wir denn jetzt so in den letzten sieben Tagen? Jetzt läuft die äh App schon eine Weile, jetzt müsst ihr ja langsam mal was kommen. Aber es waren halt bis,
gestern oder eigentlich bis heute Nacht keine Kies überhaupt veröffentlicht worden.
Also überhaupt nix, nicht nur wenig, sondern halt null nada Nierente. Und
das äh wurde mehrfach beobachtet und wurde mehrfach auch äh kommentiert und das ist wohl auch etwas, was so in der ganzen Entwicklergemeinde relativ schnell gefunden wurde, auch weil man gesehen hat, aha, es,
da auch so eine kleine Spaßbremse in dem in dem Code derzeit. Der nämlich aus so privaten ein Limit,
äh von hundertvierzig Keys gemacht hat, bevor überhaupt irgendwas rausgehauen wird. Damit man nicht irgendwie da äh irgendeine Zuordnung machen kann, dass man also nicht weiß, so ah, die Kies gehören zueinander.
Muss man vielleicht kurz erklären, also hundertvierzig ist ja relativ einfach, wie man auf diese Zahl gekommen ist, nämlich ähm zehn Personen,
Die vierzehn Tage getrackt wurden. Ja, sodass man sagt, wir releasen immer Bündel von zehn Personen, um,
irgendwie das Risiko der Identifikation von Einzelpersonen irgendwie geringer zu halten. Ja, also dass jetzt nicht jede Einzelperson sofort released wird, sondern in einem Bündel immer zehn.
Eine Entscheidung, die ich so nicht getroffen hätte. Und die zweitens, jetzt natürlich zum Problem führt, wenn es deine App erst fünf Tage gibt,
weil dann hast du mit deinen ähm.
Mit deinen hundertvierzig Keys eben, ne, brauchst du sehr viel mehr Personen als diese Zehen, um auf diese Schwelle, um diese Schwelle zu erreichen.
Genau, müssen wir nochmal kurz erklären, also was wir sagen, mit Key ist quasi ein Tag eines Infizierten ist ein Key.
So, das heißt, deswegen äh das Ganze äh durch vierzehn und deswegen äh möchte man halt in Gruppen von hundert veröffentlichen, aber jetzt waren's halt, weil weniger Kies da waren, eben sehr viel mehr und deswegen ging diese gegen eine geringe Zahl von Meldungen gar nicht erst raus.
Gruppen von,
zehn, also Gruppen von einhundertvierzig Keys, also eine Person, wenn eine Person, die App vierzehn Tage lang genutzt hat, dann lädt sie vierzehn Keys hoch und zwar einen für jeden Tag,
und das mal zehn sind hundertvierzig, das heißt das Minimum wäre immer wenn zehn Personen zusammen sind.
Ach so, ich habe gerade hundert gesagt, ne?
Ja, aber es deswegen muss jetzt.
Ich meinte, ja, ich meinte zehn. Mhm.
Dieses Limit, was ich grundsätzlich schon mal schwierig finde. Also die Sorge, die hier ist, ist folgender. Wenn,
nur eine Person hochlädt, diese vierzehn Keys,
Ja, wenn ich also mit einem Request dorthin vierzehn Keys bekomme, dann weise ich diese vierzehn Kies sind eine Person.
Und dann macht dieses gesamte äh dass es jeden Tag einen neuen Key gibt, keinen Sinn mehr. Das ist das Problem, was hier gelöst werden muss. Und deswegen sagen die alles klar, wir nehmen immer zehn, weil dann weißt du, okay, ne.
Diese es gibt jetzt hier zehn Keys, ja. Von mir aus verbirgt sich hinter jedem dieser zehn eine Person, aber du weißt nicht, wie welchen Key welche Person an welchem Tag hatte.
Die sehr viel einfachere Lösung des Problemes ist natürlich so eine Schwelle zu haben aber nicht jeden Kita da drin ist auch tatsächlich von einer Person zu nehmen sondern einfach
random noch welche mit reinzunehmen. Und man sieht es bei denen im GIT-Hub, dass sie das dann auch gescheckt haben und ähm nämlich,
Random key Padding gemacht haben. Und dass, wenn man sagt, dass im Gitter anschaut, dann ist das irgendwie,
vor zwei Tagen gemerget worden und war hier eine längere Diskussion. Was ich daraus schließe ist, na ja so.
Das Problem haben die wahrscheinlich,
ähm zu spät gecheckt, ja? Ähm und dann eben offenbar hier übers Wochenende daran gearbeitet, dass äh Problem zu lösen, dass auch äh gut.
Aber schlecht für die erste Woche dieser App, wenn man nämlich hier diese kurzen Infektionszeiträume voraussetzt, ja, dann heißt das, dass sie jetzt für die ersten Meldungen,
Was weiß ich, wenn da jetzt jemand wirklich am Dienstag oder am Mittwoch nach der,
Direkt nach der Veröffentlichung eine Meldung abgegeben hat. Die konnte jetzt keine Wirkung mehr entfalten. Natürlich konnte die unter Umständen auch keine Wirkung entfalten, weil die Kontakte noch keine App hatten und so weiter und so fort. Insofern ist das erwartbar, dass zum Staat
Meldewesen noch nicht besonders gut funktioniert,
Jetzt eben auf der technischen Seite nicht funktioniert. Und das muss natürlich schon erklären, wenn du da Kies liegen hast und du veröffentlichst sie nicht, da musst du dir natürlich dann schon mal Gedanken drüber machen. Und ähm,
Das äh ist hier ein bisschen spät, äh offenbar hat das erst stattgefunden.
Ja und vor allem.
Der der Fix war zwar schnell da, aber es hat dann noch einige Tage gedauert, bis er dann auch wirklich das Licht des Tages gesehen hat. Das sind dann wahrscheinlich noch mal weitere bürokratische äh Kaskaden in dieser Entscheidungskette äh zu beschließen, dass das jetzt sozusagen auch
gut es muss natürlich getestet werden, Leute müssen sich das anschauen, sehe ich schon äh ein, ne?
Aber da scheint mir auch noch etwas Optimierungspotenzial zu sein.
Gibt da noch ein paar andere Bereiche, wo äh Verzögerungen offensichtlich zu sein scheinen. Das hat so ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass selbst wenn ein Kiefer öffentlicht ist, muss er ja dann auch erst mal den Weg aufs Telefon finden
und da gibt's dann das Problem, dass zumindest, da wird's für mich jetzt aber noch ein bisschen unübersichtlich, wie die Lage jetzt genau ist, weil das scheint dann auf Android und äh Eiweiß teilweise ein bisschen anders zu sein,
auf jeden Fall äh ist so ein bisschen die Realität die das im Prinzip die App eigentlich nur einmal am Tag wirklich guckt,
ob denn was neues da ist und dann das Ganze,
ähm dem Telefon sozusagen zum Vergleich anbietet und sagt, hier sind neue Keys. Schau doch mal, ob da was dabei ist,
Kann es natürlich sein, dass man gerade eben gecheckt hat.
Kurz bevor der nächste Key dann auch veröffentlicht wird, dann hat man den sozusagen um eine Stunde verpasst, guckt aber dann erst dreiundzwanzig Stunden später äh nach,
Und dann findet das irgendwie vielleicht auch noch alles nachts statt und bist mit einem wirklichen User diese Warnung sieht,
ja, sind dann schnell mal zwei Tage vergangen. Es hat verschiedene Gründe, warum solche ähm Verzögerungen überhaupt
gibt? Oder warum das nicht äh häufiger gemacht wird? Äh unter anderem gibt's auch noch so, also dass man diese API jetzt nicht permanent aufrufen kann, so nach dem Motto, oh ein neuer Key, gleich mal gucken. Ähm
Ich habe zu den Eindruck, an der Stelle muss an verschiedenen Stellen nachgebessert werden, sowohl im von Apple und Google als eben auch, wie das so im Netz gehandhabt wird und über die Probleme im Backgand haben wir ja gerade gesprochen.
Das muss man vielleicht ganz kurz erläutern, also was du gerade gesagt hast, mit dem an der API, das heißt, die Corona-Warn-App selber,
sich vom Betriebssystem nicht am laufenden Band die gesammelten Keys geben lassen. Und der Grund dafür ist, dass dass die,
dass diese API quasi der App nicht traut und sagt, pass mal auf, wenn du hier jede Minute kommst, dann kannst du nachher vielleicht doch irgendwelche genaueren Aufzeichnungen darüber führen, wann hier wer, wo wen getroffen hat. Deswegen darfst du da nicht so oft drauf zugreifen.
Und ähm das ließe sich natürlich auch schöner lösen, ja, indem man nämlich diese Prüfung vielleicht mit in die API nimmt.
Ne, ist sie auch. Ist sie auch. Das, das ist sie schon. Also man.
Aber du könntest ja da also oder die App könnte dann da andere Kies reintun. Aber das kann man auf jeden Fall besser lösen als mit vierundzwanzig Stunden Beschränkungen, ne? Und das ist tatsächlich auch so, ähm hier bei meinem Testgerät, ich wollte,
mir, als ich dann heute gehört habe, ach endlich sind die, haben sie jetzt mal geschafft, Kies zu pushen? Ähm dann hat meine App sich geweigert, die abzuholen. Weil du hast ja schon.
Sie schon. Du hast ja gestern schon wie viele Witze denn noch? Ja und das ähm.
Das äh geht ist natürlich schwierig. Ähm.
Hier muss hier muss auf jeden Fall eine Optimierung her, um eben die schnellen Meldezeiträume, die ja der eine Unique Sellingpoint dieser App, ja, ist eine eine Beschleunigung des Meldeprozesses und wenn wir hier von
eben einmal zu Beginn mehreren Tagen und dann,
Auch nach dem Release zwei Tagen reden, dann wird die äh läuft die App Gefahr, ihrem Zweck nicht mehr ähm.
Gerecht werden zu können.
Hm. Bei mir ist jetzt gerade überprüft worden, vor zwei Stunden.
Und, können wir noch weiter podcasten?
Ja, alle geht noch. Allerdings meint die äh App, sie hätte jetzt keine Internetverbindung, was ich für eine freche Behauptung halte, weil das.
Du bist in Deutschland halte ich nicht für unwahrscheinlich. Es gibt dann noch äh diese übrigens auch einen
ein Back, über den sich viele beschweren, der mir auch unklar ist, das iOS Geräte irgendwie äh scheinbar random irgendwie sagen, sinngemäß eine Fehlermeldung. Ich habe jetzt hier gerade kein Foto davon,
Die Region für deine Expose Notification hat sich geändert. In diesem Land funktioniert die App nicht, die du hast.
Ja, also das sieht nach dem Back aus in iOS.
Also ich kann mir auch nur vorstellen, dass diese App halt sagt, ach okay, du bist jetzt gerade in anderes Land gegangen, musst jetzt eine andere nehmen oder so, aber ich habe ja dann auch keine Handlungsmöglichkeit, also da ist irgendwie auch noch ein Bag, der natürlich die Leute total nervt und äh irgendwie problematisch ist, weil.
Also, jeder Back ist problematisch und wenn da irgendwelche Warnmeldungen kommen, die Leute nicht verstehen, ist das äh also.
Brauche ich glaube ich nicht weiter zu erläutern. Zumal, wenn man dann sagte, okay, ich möchte etwas tun, dann kommt man irgendwie in den Settingsdialog und kann da nichts tun. Werde Pech hast, drücken die Leute und das Einzige, was man da machen kann und machen das Contact-Tracing aus, ne? Also das ist auch ein
sehr großes Problem.
Gehe mal davon aus, dass es äh relativ zeitnah einen äh Update geben wird. Die sammeln jetzt gerade die die Probleme ein und da ist so einiges, was noch gefixt werden muss,
Aber es gibt auch noch ein spezifisches Problem mit der Corona-Warn-App, nämlich dass sie zumindest bei iOS nur im deutschen App Store verfügbar ist.
Und das äh ist natürlich insofern blöd, als dass man nicht unbedingt davon,
ausgehen kann, dass alle Leute, die hier regelmäßig Zeit verbringen oder leben, äh auch tatsächlich diesen deutschen App-Store benutzen,
Wenn ich mal ein halbes Jahr im Ausland bin, dann benutze ich ja auch nicht grade äh wechsele ich auch nicht mein App Store, weil das hat ja dann.
Enorme Konsequenzen, dann musst du dich irgendwie da doppelt anmelden für jede App und dann willst du nicht da in dem Store was kaufen und gilt deine Kreditkarte nicht und kannst es nicht umziehen und so weiter und gerade für Leute, die für so ein paar Monate äh hier sind
ist es eigentlich absolut unzumutbar und ich kenne auch viele Fälle, wo Leute einfach auch aus,
anderen Gründen noch in irgendeiner Form in einem App Store eines anderen Landes äh hängen und die dann einfach schlicht nicht an diese App rankommen.
Ich habe noch nie DDF-Store
geändert bei mir, weil ich weiß, dass das einfach nur eine Welt aus Schmerzen ist und wenn du dir dann nämlich auf einmal zwei App Store Accounts zu haben
und äh irgendwie wechseln, ach, jetzt hast du aber hier die App aus dem italienischen Store oder was weiß ich, äh darfst jetzt nicht mehr, man muss jetzt nochmal Passwort alles misst. Und man darf ja auch nicht vergessen,
auch Menschen, die in diesem Land leben, haben vielleicht App Stores in anderen Sprachen.
Ja und die sind dann auch ausgeschlossen, ne. Ähm das also äh Unsinn, äh dass auf den auf einen bestimmten Appstore zu beschränken.
Ja, ich denke, da sollte die App generell noch internationaler werden. Was ich gehört habe, ist, dass das irgendwie ein Legal Problem ist, äh was ich mir zwar nicht vorstellen kann, aber das wird wohl irgendwie so auf dieser Rechtsebene äh diskutiert.
Das kann ich mir aber sehr gut vorstellen, dass das ein rechtliches Problem ist, weil also zumindest okay, in in für Europa kommst du ja wahrscheinlich klar mit Nutzungsbedingungen,
ähm dann eben in den jeweiligen Ländern.
Aufgrund der Datenschutzgrundverordnung ja eigentlich kompatibel sein müssten, aber spätestens, wenn jetzt irgendwie, was weiß ich, in der Türkei, in USA oder in sonstigen App Stores,
dieses Ding anbieten möchtest, hast du's ja mit einer über,
Juristiken und Landesgrenzen hinausgehenden Datenexportsammlung da glaube ich schon, dass da nochmal eine Juristin, pro Lanten-Tach äh die Bücher wälzen muss. Das kann ich mir schon vorstellen.
Schon sein, aber die Italiener hatten ihre App von vornherein äh im Store überall, also zumindest in deutsche.
Italiener gesehen hast, die sehen das auch alles ein bisschen lockerer, ja.
Sind das hier wieder Vorurteile oder was?
Nee, weiß ich aber auch nicht, ob die's weltweit hatten, ne. Also europaweit würde ich ja so.
Das weiß ich auch nicht.
Europaweit äh erwarte ich.
Darüber hinausgehend könnte ich mir vorstellen äh vorstellen, dass es schwierig ist. Aber Italien Italien würde ich jetzt, also klar, ich würde europaweit müsste sofort drin sein. Und dann sollte man sich im Zweifelsfall als nächstes um die um um die Türkei kümmern.
Ja oder überhaupt äh einmal um die ganze Welt. Das ist ja dann auch noch das, was jetzt aussteht, was ja derzeit einfach auch ganz offiziell noch nicht geht. Wir haben einfach noch nicht dieses,
Roaming, dieses Personen Roaming. Ja, selbst wenn ich jetzt äh nach Italien fahren würde, dort Zeit verbringe, dann ähm könnten zwar,
Meine Corona-Warn-App und die Immuniapp wunderbar ihre Keys austauschen. Ja, das ist alles äh dasselbe Ding. Nur wenn ich dann halt meine Infektionskies veröffentliche, landen die halt nicht bei Immuni in der App, weil sie einfach
nicht wüsste, wo sie die her laden soll,
haben wir jetzt schon einige Male angesprochen, ist noch nicht gelöst. Es gibt da wohl Debatten darüber, wie man denn das jetzt am besten macht, sowohl im Punkto auf eine Standardisierung. Ne, also auch das, glaube ich, verzögert
grade da so die nächsten Schritte noch ein bisschen mit ähm als eben auch,
ob man sich den nicht vielleicht zusammentut, weil es gäbe ja durchaus die Möglichkeit zu sagen, okay, die EU ist jetzt wie ein Land, wir machen das jetzt mal.
Das hat natürlich auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, dass sich noch nicht alle Länder für diese Lösung entschlossen haben, aber es scheint jetzt die Welle ähm,
zu laufen, sogar das Vereinigte Königreich hat jetzt zugegeben, dass ihr zentrales Appsystem nicht funktioniert und haben das jetzt sein gelassen und angekündigt auch oft äh Apple, Google umzusteigen,
natürlich gleich noch rumgepault und ja, aber wir haben ja unsere App ist ja eigentlich viel besser gewesen und die kann ja viel besser den Abstand messen und das ist ja, Apple hat das ja total verkackt und wir haben da auch schon angerufen, wie wie doof die doch alle sind.
Okay, also es wird dem britischen Gesundheitsminister in den letzten Monaten mal zugehört hat, weiß, dass auf seine Expertise relativ wenig zu setzen ist
stellt sich nur die Frage, wann Frankreich jetzt noch mitzieht, weil es gibt mittlerweile zwölf Länder in Europa, also zwölf Länder der EU, die alle angekündigt haben,
ähm auf das dezentrale Modell zu gehen und ich denke mal, ist jetzt noch eine Frage von einem überschaubaren Zeitraum bis,
feststellen dürfen, so EU macht das jetzt einfach mal und fertig. Ja und dann müssen sich halt noch drüber einigen,
haben wir alle einen Download-Server, benutzen wir jetzt alle die Telekom oder gibt es in irgendeiner Form so ein Roaming Modell, das,
wird wohl derzeit kräftig debattiert, wie man das macht oder ob das Protokoll dafür noch eine Erweiterung braucht oder ob man das ohne Protokollerweiterung auch schon hinbekommt.
Da müssen sie aber auch in die Pötte kommen und nicht irgendwie Protokollerweiterungen hin und her, letztendlich ist da, weißt du, Apple und Google haben jetzt diese Nummer in die Welt gesetzt, die müssen jetzt auch zumindest definieren,
wie ein Roaming technisch abzubilden ist. Ich hatte ja schon mehrmals hier betont, dass es das große Problem ist eher die Prozedure.
Man kriegt das technisch hin. Die die technische Basis dafür ist da. Äh die Lösung ist jetzt, wenn man's jetzt Euro äh in der Europäischen Union macht, müsste jedes Mitglied der Europäischen Union den Gesundheitsämtern ähm.
Anderen Mitgliedsstaaten trauen. Und ich könnte mir zum Beispiel vorstellen, äh dass das da in einigen bilateralen äh Bereichen durchaus zu Problemen führen könnte.
Mein Verständnis ist die, es gibt einen solchen Vorschlag, aber die Länder, also nicht nur die europäischen Länder, sondern irgendwie alle. Äh sind nicht unbedingt der selben Meinung.
Ja, wie das so ist. Deswegen muss, also Apple und Google sind gut damit gefahren.
Einen Standard zu setzen und zumindest für die technische Basis jetzt mal einen sicheren ähm Austausch.
Äh vorzubereiten, ähm stünde ihn gut zu Gesicht. Der darf natürlich nur den technischen Teil betreffen. Ähm.
Wie gesagt, das das Heavy Lifting überlastet sie ja eh den Ländern, also das ganze Meldewesen und das können sie auch weiterhin tun.
Ja gut, das ist natürlich ein Eiertanz, ne, weil ähm haben wir ja auch schon mehrfach besprochen. Sie haben ja nichts dagegen, eine technologische Marktführerschaft äh zu machen, aber sie wissen auch, dass wenn sie das damit übertreiben und sagen,
Wir wissen alles besser und wir machen das jetzt einfach mal so, dass sie,
dann auch sehr viel Backlash ernten würden. Von daher denke ich mal, sind sie gerade sehr darauf bedacht, hier,
Konsens voranzugehen, für unterschiedliche Maßeinheiten von von Konsens und letztlich ist ja auch das Modell, was sie jetzt gemacht haben, dadurch entstanden, dass sie den Schweizern gut zugehört haben. Also da sehe ich schon,
sehe sehe ich die Bedenken auf allen Seiten und ich bin aber auch relativ sicher, dass wir hier, wenn man sich gerade mal die Infektionszahlen in äh USA anschaut, dass dass das schon noch, dass das alles schon so schnell läuft, wie es gerade möglich ist.
Okay, das haben wir sonst noch Kritik an der Corona-Warn-App.
Bestimmt aber nicht diese Woche.
Alles klar. Dann kommen wir, das ist jetzt auch noch zur letzten Sendung, da haben wir über diesen.
Facebook FBI Exploit gesprochen und ich hatte ja ähm ein bisschen um
Diskussion und Kommentare äh zur Sendung gebeten wie ihr diesen Fall einschätzt. Ähm haben jetzt wenige zu starke mutige Urteile
zu gefällt, aber es gab da zwei Kommentare zu die ich dann doch mal noch kurz mit äh mit aufnehmen möchte. Der eine ist,
related, ja? Ähm und,
bezieht sich aber auf was anderes, aber er hat mit dem Thema zu tun. Also wir erinnern uns, Facebook hatte für das FBI einen Exploit.
Gekauft, mit dem das FBI dann einen Menschen hacken konnte, der ähm über Anonymisierungsdienste auf Facebook.
Irgendwie bedrängt und erpresst hat. So, in diesem Kontext nehme ich jetzt den Kommentar von oder
Ähm hi Linus, in der Folge
Vor dieser hattest du zum Ende erwähnt, dass du vergessen hast dich bezüglich der Geschehnisse in Münster im Kontext des Kindesmissbrauchsnetzwerk zu äußern. Auch wenn ich glaube, dass es schwierig für euch oder dich ist, zu jeder Sache die eigene Meinung halbwegs sachlich und angriffsfrei zu äußern, so habe ich
doch gehofft, dass ich eure Einschätzung zu dem Vorfall in dieser Folge höre. Holen wir gleich nach. Da Kindesmissbrauch und Terrorismus, immer das Endgegnerinnenargument,
für jede Sicherheitsdiskussion bei vielen,
zu sein scheinen, so denke ich, dass auch hier wieder deutlich hervorzuheben ist, dass nicht die Technik die Ursache war, dass so ein Scheiß passieren konnte, sondern dass es immer noch die Menschen sind, die dahinter stecken. Und siehe da.
Wie es heute auch wieder in den Medien,
zu beobachten ist, versuchen verschiedene Innenminister wieder mittels etwaiger Vorratsdatenspeicherung gegen Kindesmissbrauch vorzugehen. Langsam,
bin ich nicht mehr so sicher, ob die Vorzeitenspeicherung nicht vielleicht doch irgendwann umgesetzt wird, weil wenn man auch nur mit geringer Wahrscheinlichkeit das Thema doch,
durchkommen könnte, so trifft dieses Ereignis vielleicht doch nach mehr als dreizehn Jahren irgendwann mal ein. Okay, also ist ganz klar, ne? Vorratsdatenspeicherung ist eine seit über einem Jahrzehnt
vorgetragene Forderung.
Viele andere Überwachungsmaßnahmen sind es auch und sie finden ihren ähm.
Kristallisationspunkt immer an oder immer auch,
an den schweren Verbrechen des Terrorismus und des äh dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauchs, der da ist die Debatte,
immer sofort da, ne? Da ist sofort die Staatstrojaner Debatte da, da ist sofort die ähm
Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdebatte da, da ist auch sofort jede andere Debatte über Verschärfung von Überwachungsmaßnahmen bis hin zu Videoüberwachung und Gesichtserkennung. Da ist einmal alles da, da die
die Leute, die solche Dinge fordern, die sitzen ja quasi mit den fertigen Plänen.
In der Schublade da und warten auf den Moment, sie anzubringen. Das klingt jetzt schlimmer als es ist, ja? Auch wir warten ja mit unseren Forderungen auf politische, günstigen Moment und ähm so ist das eben äh an dieser Stelle,
auch. Insofern ähm ja, viel mehr habe ich gar nicht dazu hinzuzufügen, als das, was äh JAM hier schreibt,
also es es wird.
Häufig, auch das ist etwas, was Ursula von der Leyen damals schon vor Jahren ähm in die Welt setzte, der Eindruck erweckt, dass das Verbreiten von,
dokumentierten Kindesmissbrauch passieren würde, weil es dafür einen Markt gäbe. Und,
diese Verbreitung nicht mehr stattfinde, wenn es diesen Markt nicht mehr gäbe. Und das glaube ich.
Zu können ist eine massive Fehleinschätzung der Mechanismen, die hier wirken. Das sind.
Eindeutig inakzeptable und gefährliche Neigungen, die diese Menschen haben.
Und den Menschen muss geholfen werden, diese Neigungen irgendwie nicht mehr zu haben.
Oder dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Neigungen nicht ausgelebt werden. Und zu diesem Ausleben gehört natürlich auch der Konsum.
Derartiger ähm Dokumentationen oder auch das Begehen derartiger Taten.
Ähm ich zähle insbesondere den Konsum auch dazu, weil der ja eine ähm.
Nicht zu verachten da,
Aspekt dieser Traumatisierung ist, ne, sehr schlimm genug für die betroffenen Personen, dass das überhaupt geschehen ist, dass das dann auch noch dokumentiert ist und verbreitet wird, ist,
glaube ich, ein so schlimmer Aspekt, dass man ihn quasi nochmal in gleicher Schwere mit dazunehmen muss.
Hm
In der Bewertung.
Jetzt bin ich aber Psychologe und muss mir natürlich darüber Gedanken machen, das Ziel jeder Maßnahme muss natürlich sein, dass so etwas nicht passiert, ja? Und es.
Gleichzeitig nicht weit genug in dieser Forschung drin zu derartigen ähm ja.
Tendenzen und einer Möglichkeit, denen therapeutisch zu begegnen. Ich weiß, dass es an der ähm FU Berlin,
zusammen mit der Charité vor vielen Jahren so ein Projekt gab, ja, die überhaupt mal versucht haben, auch zu solchen Menschen in Kontakt zu kommen. Ja, weil das ist ja nichts, worüber du redest. Ähm.
Und um quasi der klebten hier in der im öffentlichen Nahverkehr immer solche Schilder, äh mögen sie Kinder mehr, als ihnen lieb ist?
Mit uns, wir interessieren uns dafür. Ich habe auch gesehen, dass es jetzt Überlegungen gibt.
Auch das natürlich echt äh schauderhaft eigentlich, ja. Ähm sage ich mal, solches Material.
Computer animiert herzustellen, um.
Prinzip eine eine Befriedigung für die Menschen herbeizuführen, ohne dass dabei andere Menschen zu Schaden kommen.
So eine Art äh.
Ja, so eine Metadomprojekt für.
Oh, das ist also es ist alles wirklich, ne? Da möchte ich denke, dass also auf jeden Fall sollte derartige, sollten derartige Maßnahmen in Erwähnung gezogen werden, weil.
Wir wahrscheinlich nicht so schnell eine Möglichkeit finden werden, so das Zustandekommen dieser Neigungen in irgendeiner Weise zu verhindern.
Und ähm auch wenn gerade in sage ich mal, in den auch sonst politisch wenig differenzierten.
Bereichen der Gesellschaft, hier halt irgendwelche lebenslangen Haftstrafen und Todesstrafen äh gefordert werden. Auch das im Zweifelsfall nicht die.
Nicht die beste Antwort wäre, ja?
Gar keine Antwort ist. Also, ich meine, es ist halt immer nur dieser Aspekt mit muss aus der äh Öffentlichkeit äh beseitigt werden, weil gefährlich.
Aber damit,
erinnerst du äh wenig an der Nachproduktion, solche Einstellungen und ähm am Ende ist das halt auch nur so ein Racheakt, der auch den Personen meist selber nicht unbedingt dann weiterhilft.
Das ist nämlich genau das Problem, ne? Das das da das kannst du ja immer erst mit den Leuten machen, wenn die schon auffällig geworden sind, unverurteilt werden. Und da hast du ja hier so krasse ähm,
Also das hier erwartet Zeiten, die sind ja noch schlimmer als bei der Corona-Warn-App, ja. Wenn das teilweise Jahrzehnte später, dass die Täter dann verurteilt werden.
Nee, das ist also das ist ein ganz dramatisches und ein ganz fürchterlicher Bereich, der denke ich für die Betroffenen.
Auch mit hohem Leid einhergeht, also für die Männer und.
Teilweise offenbar auch Frauen, die ihnen helfen. Ähm und jetzt hast du das Problem,
dass das Internet unter Umständen Situationen herbeiführt, in denen die Menschen denken, dass dieses, dass ihre Abweichung,
normal ist, ne? Wir sagen, wir sagen zum Beispiel ja äh sehr häufig, dass das für äh Homosexuelle, für Transsexuelle, für eben Menschen, die sage ich mal äh irgendeine Form von,
Sexualreferenz haben, die ähm
In einer Schulklasse voller Dreizehnjähriger nicht sofortige Zustimmung findet. Ne, die haben ja sofort Probleme. Und,
Da sagen wir eigentlich, dass das Internet einen sehr guten ähm,
sehr gute Wirkung entfaltet, weil sie Gleichgesinnte treffen, sich mit denen austauschen können. Bei diesen.
Ähm ja, Pädophilie mit Pädophile sehr falsch bezeichneten Phänomen, hast du halt.
Geht das leider nach hinten los, ne? Und dann kommen dann solche Sachen dabei raus, dass sie irgendwelche äh ja kriminelle, kleindestine Bildertausch Gruppierungen da hast. Ich
glaube nach wie vor nicht, dass das ein ein großer Markt ist, an dem sich Menschen massiv bereichern oder so, ja, dafür gibt es,
einfach Märkte, indem man sich sehr viel einfacher.
Sehr viel mit sehr viel größerer Kundschaft bereichern könnte. Ne, also ich würde immer.
Ich würde immer eher, was weiß ich, den Handel mit Substanzen,
empfehlen, wenn man irgendwie kriminell schnell Geld machen möchte, als jetzt ausgerechnet in diesem Bereich zu gehen, wo die gesamte Gesellschaft keine Gnade kennt und das aus aus gut nachvollziehbaren Gründen,
wo einfach Risiko und ähm ja.
Möglicher Gewinn in ein sehr ungünstigen Verhältnis stehen. Insofern würde ich eigentlich immer noch davon ausgehen, dass das nicht unbedingt ein kommerziell getriebener Bereich ist und,
ganz wichtig auch, ganz, ganz wichtig. Ähm ich halte die These für.
Unwahrscheinlich, dass Menschen durch den Konsum derartiger Dokumentationen,
irgendwie ermutigt werden, dass dann auch zu tun oder überhaupt derartige Präferenzen weiterzuentwickeln,
so, das ist nicht das, was ich also so habe ich nicht den Eindruck, dass Sexualität funktioniert. Also zumindest meine nicht.
Nee. Man auch nicht.
So und das war äh vielleicht noch ein Punkt, den der sich in all diesen Fällen immer zeigt, ist, dass findet im Bekannten- und Familienkreis statt.
Und ähm nicht unbedingt im Internet, ne. Also die, die tatsächlichen Taten, die da begangen werden.
Ähm ansonsten bleibt mir noch zu sagen, nun großer Erfolg der Polizei, herzlichen Glückwunsch, gut, dass das dieser äh münsteraner Münster war das, ne? Ja, oder war.
Ja, glaube ja.
Ja. Dieser münsteraner Ring da aufgedeckt wurde und natürlich auch diese IT, die da unterhalten wurde.
Wie gesagt, ursprünglich waren wir noch bei diesem ach so, möchtest du da noch was zu sagen, Tim?
Ich habe dem jetzt ehrlich gesagt wenig äh hinzuzufügen.
Äh würde ich den zweiten Kommentar von Andreas äh nochmal also wie gesagt, wir wir sind ja in diesem großen Bereich ja im Prinzip einmal hier gegen jemanden, der ähm.
Minderjährige stalkt in sozialen Netzwerken. Ähm da kommentiert Andreas. Ähm zu eurer Diskussion bezüglich,
Facebook und FBI, warum empfindet ihr das Entwickeln der Schwachstelle
problematisch. Die war ja die ganze Zeit da. Die ist ja nicht dafür gebaut worden, aus dem gleichen Grund, verstehe ich den Vorbehalt nicht gegenüber Exploit-Aufkauf, beziehungsweise
beziehungsweise Entwicklung durch das BSi. Das ist für mich das gleiche wie Security
solange wir nicht hinschauen, wird der Bug schon nicht da sein. Ähm
kürze den Kommentar ein bisschen übersehe ich da etwas oder ist die Problematik von in den Händen von offiziellen Stellen nicht einfach nur das geheim halten der selben und nicht das beschaffen,
Ja, jein, also du hast in dem Kommentar, ich weiß nicht, ob absichtlich oder unabsichtlich die beiden Begriffe Schwachstelle und verwendet und die würde ich ähm.
Nochmal kurz auseinander halten wollen, denn du hast natürlich Recht, die Schwachstelle ist da drin in diesem,
Software. Die ist da wahrscheinlich nicht absichtlich drin gelandet. Da hat irgendein Programmierer oder eine Programmiererin. Ähm keine Ahnung, nicht nachgedacht beim,
Programmieren und fertig, ja? So, dadurch ergibt geben sich Schwachstellen unterschiedlicher Schwere und wenn du eine Kombination aus Schwachstellen hast, dann,
oder eine Kombination aus Dummheiten ähm unter Umständen auch schwerwiegende Schwachstellen.
Die Schwachstelle selber kann da von mir aus Jahre oder Jahrzehnte unentdeckt liegen, bis eben jemand hinschaut. Ähm ich glaube, so die Dienstälteste Schwachstelle,
war das nicht.
War das nicht das mit den oder so? Ich weiß nicht mehr genau welche, aber ich weiß, sie war über fünfundzwanzig Jahre, ja. Die die war quasi, die war in.
Die war seit fünfundzwanzig Jahren dort. Die war damit zu dem Zeitpunkt älter als der IP-Stick von Microsoft aus,
Und äh irgendwann hat sie dann mal jemand gefunden, weil sich dann diesen Teil des Codes mal jemand angeschaut hat und gesagt hat, haha, wenn ich hier so und so mache, kann ich das System hier ausm Tritt bringen. Genau das Ausnutzen der Schwachstelle ist dann der Explode
Ja, also
Ausnutzen, die Möglichkeit, diese Schwachstelle auch tatsächlich zu verwenden, um in irgendeiner Form die Integrität, Verfügbarkeit oder Vertraulichkeit eines Systems zu verletzen ist, irgendwie aus dem Tritt zu bringen
und es in irgendeiner Weise dazu zu bringen, etwas zu tun, was von Betreiber und Programmiererinnen nicht gewünscht war. Ähm.
Und das einzige diesem Treiben dann ein Ende zu bereiten ist wiederum das Entfernen der Schwachstelle. Nun, mein Argument ist,
oder ich nicht nur meins, das ist das äh, ich denke, das gängige Argument ist, in dem Moment, wo es irgendwo eine Schwachstelle gibt,
ist äh wichtig, dass sie entfernt wird, damit nicht alle, die diese Software nutzen, dem Risiko, dass von der,
Tense oder den Wissen über diese Schwachstelle ausgeht, ausgesetzt werden. Und ähm der Security bei obscurity Argument,
ist nämlich genau das.
Die Geheimdienste oder Facebook FBI in diesem Fall sagen, ja ja, wir sind ja die einzigen, die den Exploit kennen.
Und deswegen ist das ja kein Problem. Es gibt aber trotzdem Millionen von LENUX Installationen, die diese Schwachstelle auch haben.
Und in dem Moment, wo die Schwachstelle entdeckt wird, von anderen oder der Explod, geklaut wird von anderen, stehen dann alle diese Nutzerinnen im Risiko. Das beste Beispiel dafür ist
dieser ähm Angriff und Notpetjaangriff. Weil ich jetzt als das wichtigste Beispiel nehmen würde, wo.
Ein sagen wir mal ein Sammelkistchen der NSA.
Abhanden gekommen ist, in die Hände der Shadow Brokers, einer ja, fiktiven Hackergruppe
unterschiedlichen Ländern zugeordnet wird, ähm aber die auf jeden Fall dann nach und nach Teile deren Chartcodes veröffentlicht hat. Und wir erinnern uns, es war damals so, als die,
Schwachstelle in der Windows Dateifreigabe. Veröffentlicht wurde, gab es,
Einen Monat vorher, nee, zwei Monate vorher eine Meldung an Microsoft.
Microsoft, das das war tatsächlich immer so in Monatsabschnitten. Microsoft hatte damals das Februar-Update aus irgendwelchen Gründen nicht gemacht,
Man wusste nicht genau wieso. Und der Grund war, dass sie wahrscheinlich im Februar alarmiert wurden, dann haben sie in dem März Update die Schwachstelle behoben, die,
eben Eternal Blue hieß und im April, einen Monat später haben die Shadow Brokers dann.
Den Explode Code veröffentlicht
Das heißt, und da da muss man wirklich sagen, es wird immer so behauptet, das wäre das wäre die NSA gewesen, das ist Unsinn. Die Shadow Brokers hatten jeden Tag ihres Lebens, seitdem sie die Schwachstelle hatten
Gelegenheit, sie zu veröffentlichen,
die waren es, die einen Monat gewartet haben. Es war nicht so, dass die NSA gesagt hat, ey, äh Microsoft veröffentliche mal einen äh Monat vorher den Fix als dass die die Shadow Brokers veröffentlichen
Es war viel mehr so, dass die NSA über ein Jahr lang wusste, dass die Shadow Brokers diese Schwachstelle hatten und sie nicht gemeldet hat
ja? Aber was ist passiert? Es kam also hier der Fix Shadow Brokers haben einen Monat gewartet und einen weiteren Monat dann nämlich im Mai kamen die,
massenhaften Angriffe, die eben unter bekannt wurden, wo dann hier auch, ne, Deutsche Bahn, Anzeigetafeln und was da nicht alles in Mitleid.
Heißt also, was wir als Katastrophe gesehen haben.
War im Prinzip nur ein vorsichtiger Vorgeschmack was passiert, wenn solche dann in die Öffentlichkeit gelangen und von jedem ausgenutzt werden können. Und das Einzige, was wir.
Als Möglichkeit haben, uns davor zu schützen, ist das Melden der Schwachstellen und die Beseitigung. So und genau diese Abwägung steht dieser Abwägung steht, dass.
Nutzen von Schwachstellen durch Geheimdienste entgegen.
Weil sie sagen, oh, wir haben hier einen wunderschönen Explode, wenn wir niemandem sagen, wo die Schwachstelle ist, können wir davon noch lange zehren. Und genau das,
ist tatsächlich hier passiert in diesem Fall. Ich habe das letzte Woche gar nicht so betont, weil ich dachte, es kann eigentlich gar nicht sein, weil ähm,
Tatsächlich, die Entwicklerinnen von Tales sagen, tja ähm offenbar hat dieser ganze Zinnova da zwanzig siebzehn stattgefunden.
Wir wüssten jetzt mal ganz gerne, über welche Schwachstelle das war, damit wir die ähm entsorgen können, also damit wir die beseitigen können. Und
weder Facebook noch das FBI, noch,
diejenigen, die vom vom Facebook bezahlt wurden, die Schwachstellen zu finden, hat den Tales-Leuten Bescheid gesagt und denen erklärt, wie sie die Schwachstelle loswerden. Die müssen also im Prinzip davon ausgehen.
Dass sie noch vorhanden ist. Jetzt kommt erschwerend hinzu, dass,
Tales natürlich nicht seinen eigenen Video-Player hat, sondern den ganz normalen äh genauen Video-Player benutzt, der ähm in so gut wie, also genom ist, der,
glaube ich, der am meisten verwendete Window Manager im Lenux Ökosystem. Und wenn ihr zum Beispiel benutzt, was wahrscheinlich die am meisten verwendete Linox-Distribution auf dem Desktop ist. Dann habt ihr auch diesen Player und.
Es stellt sich nun da, dass im Zweifelsfall alle UNTO Nutzerinnen und,
diesen Gnomen Video-Player haben, mit dem dieses Tales gehackt wurde, also auch die Schwachstelle haben. Und das ist genau, ne, was du ansprichst, äh Andreas, ähm,
Security bei Obscurity, die wir die wir jetzt hier alle haben, weil eben offenbar hier die ähm Strafverfolgungsbehörden,
zu einem Entschluss gekommen sind, dass diese Schwachstelle für sie nützlich ist und es ähm ihnen offenbar lieber ist, wenn wir alle sie haben.
Als äh dass sie die jetzt aufgeben und sich für den nächsten eine neue aussuchen müssen. Und das ist das Problem an dieser ganzen Angelegenheit und das macht auch für mich jetzt diese Bewertung dieses Falles noch,
Also da dadurch, dass dass ich das erst nur implizit gedacht habe, jetzt auch nochmal das in einem Artikel äh von Francesco äh bestätigt wurde,
Nee, Entschuldigung, Francesco Quatsch von Lorenzo. Ähm das äh lässt diese ganze Sache dann doch äh sehr viel einfacher bewerten.
Nämlich nicht so gut, wie ihr das gemacht habt.
Das war nicht besonders gut, wie ihr das gemacht habt und äh diese Schwachstelle wenigstens danach zu opfern, wer wenigstens das wäre so das Mindeste gewesen, dann hätte man vorsichtig darüber diskutieren können, aber das ist absolut inakzeptabel.
Ja oder sie siehst du das anders?
Nö, das sehe ich überhaupt nicht anders. Das ist äh definitiv in Atzetail. Ich meine, allerspätestens, wenn sowas irgendwie dann auch mal rauskommt so. Also ich meine, dann muss es jetzt einfach geliefert werden, ne.
Unglaublich.
Das ist einfach eine Frechheit. Frechheit.
Und das ist, das ist ein, übrigens, das Kernargument, deswegen äh danke Andreas, dass du diese Debatte auch dann noch mal hier entfacht hast, warum wir uns gegen.
Sämtliches, staatliches Hacking aussprechen. Ja, weil eben hier immer derartige,
ähm Abwägungen stattfinden, weil man braucht nun mal eine Schwachstelle, um diese Schadsoftware auf den Zielgeräten anzubringen. Und da würde ich jetzt,
grade auch einfach mal ein Thema vorziehen, was wir ähm eigentlich erst später in den Shownotes hätten, denn.
Unsere Freunde bei Amnesty International haben mal wieder einen Staatstrojaner in der freien Wildbahn gefunden. Ähm
Sie hatten zwanzig neunzehn äh zum ersten Mal, glaube ich, berichtet über äh Schadsoftware von der NSO Group. Ähm,
Es gibt ja im Prinzip zwei große internationale.
Bekannte Hersteller von Schadsoftware für Mobil, Betriebssysteme, der bekannte.
Im Moment noch ist äh Finn Fischer.
In Deutschland zumindest bekannter, insbesondere, weil das Unternehmen auch deutsche Münchner Wurzeln hat und weil ähm,
Ja, weil weil es hier in Deutschland einfach die große Rolle spielt. Ähm da darauf bezog sich ja auch die Veröffentlichung von Torsten und mir.
Dezember diesen Jahres, als wir den Finn Fischer Trojaner Fins bei äh Mobile für Android analysiert hatten.
Ähm könnt ihr euch nochmal den Vortrag anschauen, der hat noch nicht genug Views.
Was? Echt nicht?
Äh ja das wurde doch da, das hat einen Torsten und Ulf Buhrmeier präsentiert, weil das ja im Rahmen des,
Strafverfahrens wegen Verstoß gegen Exportkontrollen war. Ne, also Hintergrund an der Stelle war ja, es gab Exportrestriktionen, solche Software aus Deutschland,
zu verkaufen und dieser dieser Trojaner wurde eingesetzt in der Türkei. Nach dem Inkrafttreten der Exportrestriktion und die Analyse, die Torsten und ich da durchgeführt haben, war quasi
herauszufinden, ob dieses Stück Schadsoftware vor oder nach dem Inkrafttreten der Exportrestriktionen.
Genau, wo er dann wo ihr dann nachgewiesen habt, dass das äh danach war, weil halt Libris verwendet wurden.
Genau, da haben wir bei mehrere Librarys, die verwendet wurden, nachgewiesen hier. Das Ding wurde gebaut nach diesem Zeitpunkt.
Und hat gleichzeitig Ähnlichkeiten zu Dingen, die vor diesem Zeitpunkt gebaut wurden, um quasi auch diese Kette,
darzustellen. Ja, dass das Verfahren, ich weiß gar nicht genau, wie der Stand da gerade ist, die Anzeige ist eben raus und da da kümmert sich dieses, das heißt nicht BAMF, sondern anders.
Irgendwie Güter und aus für oder sowas. Bamf ist ja Bundesamt für Migration und Flüchtlinge. Und dann gibt's noch irgendwie diese Ausfuhrkontroll,
kümmert. Äh wir haben den technischen Teil gemacht. Ähm wie man merkt an meiner an meiner äh juristischen Kompetenz.
Du meinst die BAFA.
BAFA. Nicht zu verwechseln mit Garfer. Okay, Garfa ist Google, Google, Apple, Facebook, Amazon. So, jetzt hatten also,
ähm,
Amnesty International hat ein da arbeitet ähm unter anderem Claudio, der äh ein von mir sehr geschätzter Forscher in dem Bereich ist und die haben jetzt ähm oft bei einem Marokkaner marokkanischen.
Äh Journalisten. Ähm.
Wieder äh Schadsoftware auf dem Telefon gefunden, weil sie davon ausgehen, dass sie eben ähnlich Ähnlichkeiten zu den vorherigen schon bei anderen,
Journalisten gefundenen Samples der NSO Group haben und sie,
gehen davon aus, dass das durch Netzwerk Injection gemacht wurde, also durch bis in einem nicht vertrauenswürdigen Netzwerk und dir wird dann eben andere Software untergeschoben, als du erwartest. Nicht ganz so,
einfach äh muss ich hier, glaube ich, auch nicht im Detail erklären. Entscheidend ist, dass die NSO-Group dieses ähm Unternehmen, was diesen Staat zueinander herstellt, ähm.
Eine Human Rights Policy veröffentlicht hat, weil sie ja immer wieder ihre ihr Staatstrojaner in sage ich mal, in so anderen Gesellschaftsformen gefunden wird als den demokratischen.
Und vor allem im Einsatz gegen Demokraten, ja? Und ähm.
Dieser ähm drei Tage nachdem NSO Group ihre Human Rights Policy veröffentlicht hatte, ähm.
Scheint hier offenbar dieser Angriff stattgefunden zu haben und ging dann auch weiter bis sie bis Amnesty eben diese Beweise vorgelegt hat.
Ähm also NSO-Group, diese da weiß man also was von ihren Menschenrechtspolices da zu halten ist.
Und auch hier wird es, also wenn sie hier sagen, durch äh Netzwerk Injection, hat das stattgefunden, dann muss da eine Schwachstelle zum Einsatz gekommen sein, die es sonst, die sonst nicht.
Die man schließen kann, ja? Und die hier ausgenutzt wird und die uns allen auch noch zum Nachteil gereichen kann. Und das ist die dann doch sehr schwierige Abwägung.
Bei ähm bei solchen solchem staatlichen Hacking, dass es immer diesen
Nicht betrachtete Feld gibt, wie viele andere Menschen sind von der Schwachstelle betroffen und wie viel Schadenspotential haben wir da? Und spätestens seit muss uns allen klar sein, was dieses Potential ist.
Dieses Schadenspotential. Und die Folge daraus ist, dass man jedes IT-System immer auf dem aktuellen Stand halten muss und dass es,
dass man jede Schwachstelle auch immer melden und auf ihre Beseitigung hinwirken muss, weil einfach der Schaden, den sonst die gesamte Gesellschaft und das Schadenspotenzial und Risiko, in das die ganze Gesellschaft gebracht wird,
immer größer ist, als der Einzelfall.
Und das ist natürlich immer äh das das wird dann im Detail, ne, sagt dann eben, ja wie sollen die Mädels sich da jetzt auf Facebook belästigen lassen, nur damit ähm
damit die das Lenux-Ökosystem nicht gehackt wird. Nein, das ist nicht die Abwägung, die hier stattfindet, sondern wenn eine Schwachstelle bekannt wird.
Da muss sie beseitigt werden. Und erst recht,
erst recht, wenn man sich schon auf das auf das Lippury Slow begeben hat, hier eine spezifisch, eine Schwachstelle zu suchen und einen Exploy zu beauftragen für einen spezifischen Angriff auf einen Straftäter
erst dann erst recht muss dieser ähm das Wissen, was da jetzt in die Welt gesetzt wurde, über diese Schwachstelle eben auch,
mit der Welt geteilt werden, damit andere sich schützen können. Ja, so. Hoffentlich Donald Trump, dass wir mir am, dass wäre mir am liebsten.
Leider hat Donald Trump jetzt einen äh.
Angriff ja doch sehr ziemlich genau in das Herz unserer Community vorgenommen.
Und der ist ein bisschen, muss ich ein bisschen ausführlicher erklären und auch ein Transparenzhinweis dazu geben, den ich äh an geeigneter Stelle anbringe.
Und zwar gibt es in den USA seit ungefähr acht Jahren den sogenannten Open Technology Fund, Open Tech Fund. Das ist eine ähm Organisation, die.
Dem über mehrere Mutterorganisationen am Ende dem Statypartment unterliegt, also dem Außenministerium
Und zwar hat das USA Media. Da drunter gibt's eine Organisation, die heißt Radio und dieses Radio hat mit seinem Anteil seines Budgets diesen Open Tacum.
Der open tech fand. Ähm schüttet so irgendwas zwischen fuffzehn und zwanzig Millionen US-Dollar aus und hat seit
zweitausendzwölf, also vierhundertfünfzig Millionen US-Dollar an ähm Funding ausgegeben für Open-Source-Projekte. Es kann sein,
dass äh in diesen vierhundertfünfzig Millionen US-Dollar auch der Betrieb des Fans drin ist, aber das sind nur ein paar Angestellte.
So, die fördern Open-Source-Projekte, die,
im weitesten Sinne, dem Umgehen von Zensur und Überwachung.
Dienlich sind und somit am Ende die Meinungsfreiheit stärken. Jetzt muss man kurz zu der Geschichte solcher ähm.
Organisationen einen Hintergrund geben,
wenn das also das Außenministerium der USA, ne, mit mehreren, mehreren Millionen US-Dollar jährlich, ähm also Maßnahmen zur,
Zensurumgehung fördert, dann hat das natürlich politische Ziele
und man sieht ja hier, ne, wenn das irgendwie unterliegt und so, dann kann man sich auch ungefähr vorstellen, was diese politischen Ziele sind, nämlich,
Letztendlich die Stärkung von Demokratie in asiatischen Ländern, ja? Und weltweit.
Ähm wir wissen, dass die USA ähm.
Mit dem Stärken der Demokratie in anderen Staaten mitunter auch wirtschaftliche Interessen verfolgt. Also wir sind da in einem etwas.
Haarigen Bereich, wo man sich genau anschauen muss, was passiert denn mit diesem Geld? So, den Teil habe ich vor vorhergesagt, äh vorausgestellt.
Schauen wir mal auf die Projekte, die dort gefandet werden. Die bekanntesten Projekte, die vom OTF gefundet werden und zwar maßgeblich, sind wahrscheinlich auch unter unseren Hörerinnen und Hörern,
Das Torprojekt mit vielen Millionen US-Dollar,
und zum Beispiel auch der, bei vielen Leuten sehr beliebte Messenger Signal. Ähm hier jetzt mein Transparenzhinweis. Ich habe auch in zwei Projekten mitgewirkt, die vom Open Tech Fund gefördert wurden
Und zwar ist das einmal das Projekt äh GSM Map, wo wir eine ähm Weltkarte der,
Sicherheitskonfiguration von Mobilfunknetzen,
erstellt haben, um zu zeigen, bei welchem Provider welche Angriffsmethoden funktionieren und welche nicht.
Und das Projekt Snoop Snatch, welches ähm,
auf inzwischen ja sehr alten Android-Version. Ähm die Möglichkeit bietet,
zu erkennen, ob bestimmte Netzwerkangriffe gerade stattfinden, wie zum Beispiel SS sieben Lokalisierung und im.
Also Telekom, Netzwerk und Abfang von Verbindungen über das Mobilfunknetz.
Genau. Zu teilen haben wir da eben Detektions Algorithmen drin, auch mit Vorarbeit von Tobias Engel. Ich wollte nur kurz darauf hinweisen, diese beiden Projekte wurden auch vom OTF gefundet. Ich war in diesen Projekten beteiligt.
Ähm Torsignal ähm.
So was wie Rise Up, äh kriegt dann da auch irgendwie ähm ne, mal Projektförderungen, ähm.
Ich ey die Liste der geförderten Projekte ist so lang
Ähm müssten wir mal gerade ganz kurz draufgehen, aber ach hier ähm Global Leagues, ja, also irgendwelche Whistleblower Plattformen. Es ist immer, also es geht immer in Richtung ähm
Autonomie und Abwehr gegen Überwachung,
und um äh und die Umgehung von Zensur. Das ist im Prinzip die Ausrichtung dieses Projektes. Ähm und.
So wenn ich mich nicht täusche, ich kenne zumindest kein Projekt, was von denen gefördert wurde, was nicht am Ende Open Source war, ja? Also ähm,
Ein signifikanter Anteil auch der Sicherheits- und Anonymisierungstechnologien, die viele von unseren Hörerinnen nutzen, wurde eben durch viele Millionen US-Dollar.
Hiervon, vom Open Technology Fund gefördert.
Die jetzt ist es so, dass diese USA Media, also das Teil, was dann direkt im State Epartment unterstellt ist, einen neuen.
Bekommen hat, nämlich Michael Pack, der äh eher rechtskonservativ ist ähm hm sehr sehr große Nähe zu Steve Bennon aufweist und zu Breitbart,
ja? Ähm der wurde vor zwei Jahren schon.
Rechtsradikalen Blockdar.
Hetzblock, ja.
Und der wurde vor zwei Jahren nominiert, dann gab es erst noch viel Widerstand und jetzt hat gab's dann Druck aus dem Weißen Haus und jetzt wurde er äh bestätigt als Chef äh der USA Media.
Obwohl gerade noch ein Korruptionsverfahren gegen ihn läuft. Also ganz klassischer Trampist und Bennenis und.
Gleichzeitig gibt es jetzt eine Lobbybemühung, die die sich sehr spezifisch an ähm diesen Pack setzt, äh widmet und,
ähm an den Mike Pense, die also sagen, ey, dieser open tac fand, da müssen wir mal bei.
Das Geld wird da irgendwie äh nach unklaren Kriterien verteilt und das sind ja alles Open-Source-Projekte. Äh da da sehen wir irgendwie nicht die wirtschaftliche Förderung in den USA und wir fänden das ganz gut.
Wenn da jetzt mal von folgenden Unternehmen ähm closed-source Lösungen,
würden und jetzt sollte man quasi am besten dieses Board, da gibt's also quasi ein weltweit besetztes
hochkarätig besetzt ist, ähm Advisor, die dann quasi die Jury machen und bei den Empfehlungen helfen und immer darauf achten, ne, dass das halt sinnvolle Projekte mit
also neue Probleme mit realistischen Ansätzen, angehen, gefördert werden.
Das müsst ihr mal alles weghegeln. Und dem vorausgegangen ist vor einen Anruf.
Einer Talkshow von Steve Bannon. Und was wir da jetzt gleich hören, Tim macht den Einspieler schon mal bereit. Ist also quasi,
Steve Bannon, der da in einer Talkshow sitzt und er hat einen Anruf von einem Call-In User, also irgendjemand, der jetzt quasi,
erklärt, was in der Regierung nicht gut läuft und er beklagt sich dort über eine spezifische Person.
Lippy Lou, die nämlich den OTF, wenn ich das richtig erinnere, äh gegründet hat und auch Präsidentin von Radio Free Ager,
wurde. Ähm ich kenne Libilo, ich habe die, weil ich ja äh in Open Techund Projekten war, auch bei verschiedenen Treffen,
gesehen und hab auch nach der Trump-Wahl mit ihr gesprochen und sagte so ey boah habt ihr nicht Angst dass dieses ganze Ding jetzt irgendwann mal denen auffällt? Und nun,
Hier sehen wir jetzt in diesem Ausschnitt, das ist ihnen aufgefallen.
Und was der Benen da sagt, ist, er fragt einfach nur, wie heißt wie ist nochmal der Name? Und er hat dabei einen Stift in der Hand und schreibt das auf ein Blatt Papier.
Und das ist so krass, ja? Und ähm.
Geht klar.
Ja und Libi ist jetzt äh zurückgetreten worden.
Und ähm es sieht jetzt eben, dass es nicht die einzige ebenfalls die Führung des äh Sendermittel East Broadcasting Radio, Radio, Radio konnten alle gehen
Und ähm jetzt ähm,
Leiterin von Voice of America sind zurückgetreten und da wird jetzt quasi richtig aufgeräumt. Und das habe ich lange befürchtet schon.
Weil das sind alles so Clinton und Bobama, Ära, Freiheit, Open Saurs, ne? Internetfrieden Projekte, die da ähm,
Ich kann nur einfach sagen, absolute Leuchtturmprojekte sind, ne, also mit all seinen Problemen ist Thor immer noch das Beste, was wir haben
und der Messenger Signal ist auch das Beste, was wir haben. Ja, äh von der von der Verschlüsselung. Es gibt Probleme, äh es gibt Leute, die das nicht gut finden, dass der Andi tatsächliche Telefonnummer gebunden ist, aber so, dass dort zur
wenn nun kommende Verschlüsselungsprotokoll ist äh beispiellos. Und jetzt,
ist also wirklich.
Sichtbar, dass diese, wie gesagt, ungefähr fünfzehn Millionen US-Dollar ähm und über ach, hier guck mal, das Projekt Repreducableds, ja, von das wir gerade noch erwähnt hatten. Die wurden auch vom open Tech Fund äh gefördert, ja, denn.
Klar.
Also ne, das geht so richtig in Wire guard, diese neue äh schlanke VPN Lösung, ja? Ähm da geht, da geht's wirklich richtig in in tolle, wichtige, gute Projekte.
Ähm ähm der Tor Browser für für Mobiltelefone. Browser heißt ja glaube ich nicht Tor Browser. Onions on Apples, ja, also richtig, da da passiert richtig Kram, ja? Und genau der Kram, nämlich,
immer kein Geschäftsmodell hat, weil es eine Open-Source-Technologie für Sicherheit ist. Ja, und eben kein Produkt eines Unternehmens.
Glaube, ich habe jetzt lange genug gesagt, äh wie wie wichtig und wie gut der Open Tack fand ist und was wir alles nicht hätten ohne den open tech fand,
Und jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch sagen,
Das ist ein riesiges Problem, das wir als gesamte Welt, ja, da so eine starke, einseitige Abhängigkeit von den USA hatten. Es gibt in Deutschland,
hier mal, ne, diesen Prototype Pfand, die dann mal irgendwie so, ne, mit großem Bohei und Maximal Förderung von im fünfstelligen Bereich dann mal ähm so ein Milinchen ausgeben
ne? Und der ist, ich will den jetzt gar nicht ähm.
Kleinreden. Ähm aber der ist natürlich ein Bruchteil von der von der Stärke des open Takfs. Also hier äh Let's and Grip wurde vom Open Take Fund mit unterstützt, ne.
Und wir haben, glaube ich, in ganz Deutschland, äh in ganz Europa bei weitem nicht eine solche Fördersumme,
wie sie hier der Open Tech Fund bereitgestellt hat. Insbesondere mit dieser hohen Transparenz, mit dieser äh mit einem diversen Team, mit einem Advisory Board aus allen, also sie haben sich sehr viel Mühe gegeben, die.
Die Projekte wirklich hochkarätig auszuwählen und zu besetzen. Und,
Es ist jetzt, ja, steht das große Risiko. K neun Mail nutzen viele unter Android für PGP-E-Mails, ne. Ähm, es stehen also jetzt,
Dieses Funding steht auf dem Spiel und damit eine ganze Reihe an Projekten, die wirklich ähm.
Bedroht sind. Tales natürlich auch. No Script, das ähm.
Browser Plugin, was viele vielleicht äh benutzen. Also da da haben wir jetzt ein riesen Problem und.
Das wird sich wahrscheinlich jetzt nicht mehr durch Protest lösen können. Es gibt jetzt eine große ähm Protestbewegung, ja, wo wir haben dann auch als Chaos-Computer-Club eine Pressemitteilung und so weiter dazu geschrieben. Aber,
Ich denke, der Protest, der sich jetzt da noch bemerkbar macht, der wird zumindest die Trump-Regierung nicht mehr umstimmen.
Und das einzige, was da jetzt noch zu gewinnen ist, ist das der Kongress, sage ich mal, das Funding für dieses Jahr noch verabschiedet. Und dann,
muss man vielleicht hoffen, dass vielleicht,
die US-amerikanischen Wählerinnen zur Besinnung kommen und was anderes wählen und dann könnte eventuell der Open Tak in der Form überleben, wie,
Sich jetzt hier zu einer wichtigen Stütze der freien Welt gemacht hat, ansonsten ist der jetzt bald vorbei. Und ähm.
Das ist äh gefährlich. Deswegen die klare Konsequenz, die wir hier auf europäischer Ebene daraus ziehen müssen, ist ähm.
So ein Funding herzustellen. Und zwar es gibt ja jetzt quasi, wir haben jetzt acht Jahre lang beobachten können, wie man das enorm erfolgreich machen kann mit ähm
wirklich guten Projekten, ne. Open Open Wisma System ist, wie gesagt, Signal, mit Tor, mit Global Leaks, mit ähm Mailvelope, mit also wirklich allen möglichen,
wirklich coolen Kram und das wird jetzt in Deutschland und Europa.
Auf einmal echt ein akutes Problem. Und da können wir nur hoffen, dass wir jetzt eben genug Gehör finden,
wie wichtig diese Projekte sind, um jetzt mal endlich auch die Europäische Union in den.
An den Punkt zu bringen, diese Projekte zu fördern, weil das eben im Interesse aller ist. Und weil das kompromisslose Sicherheitsprojekte sind, vor denen die Welt profitiert, die eben nicht.
Am Ende sich einem politischen, einer politischen Steuerung unterwerfen. Das ist ja das,
und das schöne an IT-Sicherheit, dass sie eben nicht für den einen und für den anderen, sondern immer funktioniert.
Oder immer nicht funktioniert.
Ja, ich meine, das wäre natürlich jetzt auch wirklich eine eine vergleichsweise günstige Methode, ähm Trump da den Stinkefinger zu zeigen.
Ja, also ich meine, wir reden hier von wenigen Millionen Euro pro Jahr, wenn ich's nicht richtig verstanden habe. Das ist ja jetzt im Rahmen einer Förderung, die von der EU ausgehen könnte, eher so Pippifax.
Bruchteile eines Jäger neunzig Tim.
Ja gut, ich meine, da,
kriegst du natürlich jeden Etat problemlos mit äh gegengerechnet und das wird ja auch gemeinhin getan. So viele Jäger neunzig hat's aber nie gegeben, wie sie schon gegengerechnet wurden. Ähm.
Aber stimme ich dir natürlich äh zu. Man soll vielleicht jetzt nochmal sagen, dieses, die Projekte sind dann vorbei. Klar, das sind alles Open-Source-Projekte. Ja, logisch, sonst würden sie ja auch gar nicht diese dieses Attribut für Open äh erfüllen.
Selbstverständlich werden die nicht morgen von der Platte gelöscht, nur wenn's da dieses Funding nicht mehr gibt.
Ne? Es wird immer Leute geben, die solche Projekte in irgendeiner Form noch beibehalten. Nur ist halt schon ein Unterschied, ob du solche Projekte so komplett aus so och ja,
nichts zu tun manchmal. Äh mach's so oder ob Leute wirklich ihre Zeit freigekauft bekommen, die sie dann eben nicht für,
andere Projekte aufbringen müssen, die ja vielleicht gut bezahlt werden, aber eben nicht.
Den selben Value haben. Und das ist schon.
Eine eine Diskussion, die wir ja auch aufm, auf einer anderen Ebene hier auch schon mal gehabt haben, als es um die Problematik,
mit Gemeinnützigkeit an sich geht und die zunehmende Maße eingeschränkte Anerkennung von Gemeinnützigkeit in Deutschland, nicht wahr? Wir haben ja verschiedene Organisationen, denen so jetzt politische Betätigungen vorgeworfen wird und,
politische Betätigung ist jetzt auf einmal nicht mehr gemeinnützig und auch grundsätzlich das Problem, dass Open-Source-Entwicklung,
nicht per se als gemeinnützig anerkannt werden kann.
Ja? Also das finde ich ein Unding für diese Zeit, dass einfach äh ist kein Kriterium gibt,
wo Softwareentwicklung einfach mal so reinfällt. Wenn du heutzutage irgendwie gemeinnützigen Apparat haben willst, der
Open Source unterstützen soll. Wo so jeder, der mit dem Phänomen halbwegs,
Bekannt ist, sagen würde so, ja klar, macht ja auch voll Sinn, ne? Leute kriegen Kohle und alles, was dabei rauskommt, kommt allen zugute, weil ist Open-Source und kann einfach verwendet werden, ne.
So nee, geht aber nicht. Da kommt das Finanzamt und sagst du, ja sicher, wenn die Entwicklung und so
verstößt ja gegen die Prinzipien von Gemeinnützigkeit. Wir wir brauchen hier was, wo ganz allgemeines Gefasel und Geschwurbel drin ist, was möglichst nicht konkret ist. Wenn sie dann mal das mit der Software dann mal alles rausnehmen, dann können wir das vielleicht mal anerkennen.
Und das ist natürlich auch etwas, was sich in dem Zuge auch ändern müsste, denn das würde wahrscheinlich auch eine ganze Menge Druck wiederum von solchen Förderbedürfnissen.
Nehmen, weil sich dann einfach auch mal Organisationen bilden könnten, sagen könnten, so, okay, wir fördern hier die Entwicklung solcher Projekte, wir sind gemeinnützig, her mit den Spenden, geht die Hälfte schon mal wieder in Topf und, äh, dann, äh, läuft der Hase.
Und ähm die Gemeinnützigkeit also,
Signal und die das Axelotölprotokoll, was da zum Einsatz kommt, ja, das ist am Ende in dem WhatsApp Messenger eingeflossen.
Das darf man nicht vergessen. Das werden die sich auch noch mal, da werden die auch nochmal an an ähm an Facebook eine Rechnung für geschrieben haben. Aber das ist überhaupt diese, dass diese Technologie entwickelt wurde, ja? Ein,
verschlüsselter, operabler, für normale Menschen bedienbarer, Ende zu Ende verschlüsselter Messenger.
Das ging eben nur, weil's da, weil man dafür kein Geschäftsmodell brauchte. Ne, oder das ging oder das das ging nur ohne Geschäftsmodell. Und
Der Nutzen ist dann eben tatsächlich in der Allgemeinheit. Also ein starkes Plädoyer, wer grade noch ein paar Millionen überhat, eine für mich, den Rest in Open-Source-Projekte und ähm
Wir brauchen da eine eine saubere Funding-Struktur und da hat der tatsächlich beispielhaft
Wirklich, das kann kann als wirklich als Beispiel gelten, wie die das als Organisationsstruktur gemacht haben, wie die sich um das Communitybuilding gekümmert haben, wie die die Auswahl getroffen haben,
Ähm das ist wirklich schon was sehr, sehr Gutes, was da gemacht wurde und man kann es jetzt kopieren. Die Amis wollen's ja offenbar nicht haben.
Übrigens, weil ich jetzt den Prototyp nur so am Rande hatte, ne. Ähm sieht ja auch ähm,
gute Freundinnen und Freunde von uns dabei. Ähm eine eine Lösungsmöglichkeit wäre natürlich vor allem auch das Budget, das Prototyp fand's einfach mal äh anzupassen.
Um. Wenn ich jetzt schon von, sage ich mal, schlüsselfertigen Lösungsmöglichkeiten reden.
Ja, da hat sich auf jeden Fall gezeigt, äh was so möglich wäre, ne. Aber auch hier Gemeinnützigkeit würde generell.
Helfen, also beim Prototyp ist das ja beim UKF, glaube ich, äh untergebracht und da liegt Gemeinnützigkeit vor, aber der Aufwand, sowas zu machen ist einfach zu.
So, jetzt haben wir ähm eine weitere schlechte Nachricht.
Und zwar haben wir über das Gesetz zur Bekämpfung des Rechtsextremismus und der Hasskriminalität gesprochen. Ähm eine letztendlich Verschärfung des Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetzes, ähm bei dem nun.
Also beim aktuellen Netzwerkdurchsetzungsgesetz ist es ja so, dass strafbare Inhalte irgendwie binnen vierundzwanzig Stunden gelöscht werden sollen. Nun sollen sie auch direkt an das Bundeskriminalamt gemeldet werden.
Und das BKA soll dann eben prüfen und gegebenenfalls ermitteln. Dabei soll es zum Beispiel gehen, um irgendwelche Inhalte mit volksverhetzenden Inhalten oder Androhungen oder sonstwas, ja? Und.
Diese direkte Meldung an das BKA ist natürlich äußerst problematisch, denn diese.
Also da da wird ja, es kommt ja dann immer zu einem Over, einem am einem Overblocking quasi, das heißt, da hast du dann auf einmal eine eine solche Datenbank bei den,
Verfolgungsbehörden und diese es wird dann die die Bestandsdaten,
Auskunft ausgeweitet, ja? Neben Namen und Anschrift können die dann nämlich auch die Kennungen, mit denen der Zugriff auf die Konten auf die Nutzerkonten stattgefunden hat oder Endgeräte und ähm.
Ähnliches zugreifen. Ja, also es gibt quasi äh.
Du kannst nicht nur sagen, okay, sag mal den Nutzernamen, sondern was was nutzt er denn da so? Was hat er denn da für Computer, ja? Ähm was hat er denn? Was speichert er zum Beispiel in der Cloud? Welche Spiele nutzt er denn, welche Chatdienste hat er denn da jetzt registriert? Je nachdem, was da so alles zu holen ist, ja?
Und ähm auch möglich ist das Abfragen von Passwörtern und Sicherheitskennungen ähm.
Allerdings unter Richtervorbehalt und.
Besonders schweren Straftaten. Ja, also es gibt jetzt quasi soll dann eine Passwortherausgabe geben,
in diesem Kontext. Jetzt gab es von der App Opposition ähm den Vorschlag eines mehrstufigen Verfahrens
nicht sofort diese ganzen Bestandsdaten und alles an das BKA gemeldet werden, sondern ein zweistufiges Verfahren zum Einsatz kommt. Also erst die Daten
gesichert werden, äh diejenigen, die die Vorratsdatenspeicherungsdebatte verfolgen, kennen den Begriff, also schnell schockfrosten
wo also nicht für alle eine Vorratsdatenspeicherung stattfindet, sondern die bei einer Beschwerde die Daten von einem Account.
Einer Vorratsdatenspeicherung unterzogen werden, also sie werden eingefroren, die werden nicht gelöscht
Und es liegen dann dort tiefgefroren, bis sie dann mit Richtervorbehalt zugegriffen werden oder nicht. Ja, also eine Idee zu sagen, okay, wir müssen nicht alle überwachen, sondern man kann quasi jemanden taggen
dann werden die Daten dann dann hört die hört das Löschen auf, die Daten werden bereitgehalten, aber für den Zugriff braucht's dann nochmal ein.
Richterinnenvorbehalt. Das wollten die hier auch empfehlen,
Ja? Und haben gesagt, komm, ähm er ist quick und wenn dann das BKA aus dem
Text einen konkreten Anfangsverdacht hat, dann können die Daten anschließend weitergegeben werden. Das heißt, nicht nur alles, was irgendjemand meldet, kommt dort an, direkt mit deinen Bestandsdaten, sondern.
Ähm nur wenn das BKA dann sagt, okay, da könnten wir uns echt mal mit auseinandersetzen. Ähm das ist dann halt eben,
da dran geht. Na ja, äh hat sich nicht durchsetzen können, obwohl ähm die Opposition, insbesondere Renate Künast, sich da ausgesprochen hat, auch Ulrich Kälber, Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte und jetzt wurde das äh beschlossen,
Ja, man kann sich nur anschauen, wer sich alles dagegen ähm ausgesprochen hat.
Beschlossen wurde noch nicht das Gesetz, sondern dieser äh Entwurf für das Gesetz wurde.
Dieser Entwurf, ja, genau. Und jetzt gibt's also, ne, den, es gibt also jetzt eine Verdachtsdatenbank,
in einem polizeilichen Zentralregister bei BKA, ja, nichts anderes ist das, ja. Diese Meldepflicht für die Dienst dann bei Anbieter führt dann unweigerlich dazu, dass sie
mehr dorthin leiten, als zu wenig, ja? Und dann bist du in dieser zentralen Datenbank und,
Unternehmen können natürlich diese Strafbarkeit gar nicht abschließend bewerten. Das ist eben das, was mit diesen dem begegnet werden sollte.
Und ähm der Bitcoin war dagegen, der IT-Verband Bitcom, ja, der Eco war dagegen und die.
Bundesjustizministerin hatte als,
Verteidigung vorzubringen. Ja äh das dient ja dem Schutz aller Menschen, die von Rassisten und Rechtsextremisten bedroht und diffamiert werden. Und das ist eine Naivität, der ich mich kaum,
ich mir kaum vorstellen kann, weil wir kennen ja wie wir sehen ja häufig, wie diese Melderei bei sozialen Netzwerken, Twitter oder sonst was, irgendwie so ein.
Auch koordiniert stattfindet, um Leute abzuschalten. Ne, da hast du regelmäßig irgendwelche, die mal wirklich ein eindeutig
von der Meinungsfreiheit gedeckten Tweet ab, sondern und dann auf einmal ihren Account gesperrt kriegen für vierundzwanzig Stunden oder für ein paar Wochen, einfach nur, weil ein paar Leute halt auf melden gedrückt haben. Und dann eben lange Zeit brauchen, um da wieder rauszukommen. Das,
Es steht natürlich hier das Risiko im Raum, dass dieser,
dann auch stattfindet. So, weißt du? Ey, guck mal hier, der Neumann gefällt uns nicht, lass mal lass mal zusehen, dass der möglichst oft in der BKA-Datenbank landet, ne? Das ist also.
Ja vor allem irgendwie Zugriff der Polizei aus weiten, um vor Rechtsextremismus zu schützen.
Ja, klingt auch nicht nach der besten.
Könnte man ja auch nochmal in die Nachrichten schauen so, ne.
Also allein überhaupt davon, also wenn eine Justizministerin davon ausgeht, dass ein bestimmtes Gesetz geeignet wäre, sich gegen eine bestimmte Art von politischer,
Orientierung,
zu richten, dann muss sie, glaube ich, sich nochmal darüber Gedanken machen, dass sie genau das Problem der Juristerei, dass sie eben nicht sagen kannst, wir machen jetzt mal eben ein Anti-Nazi-Gesetz, ähm ohne dass du dir überlegen musst, welche Folgen das hat, wenn es eben.
Anders stattfindet.
Ja und vor allem so so eine Gesetzgebung ist auch an sich problematisch. Also ist, glaube ich, auch verboten. Da kommt dann schnell mal das Verfassungsgericht und sagt so, das ist jetzt hier nur um das in die eine Richtung zu schieben und der Rest wurde nicht bedacht.
So auf jeden Fall haben sie sich jetzt dafür entschieden. Für diesen Gesetzesentwurf und ähm das heißt.
Da wird man dann jetzt gucken müssen, dass der nicht so beschlossen wird und dann wird man gucken müssen, dass man dagegen klagt und dann geht der ganze Theater wieder von vorne los.
Kommt wieder das Bundesverfassungsgericht und sagt, aber Vorratsdatensprechung hatten wir das nicht schon mal.
Langweilig.
Einer älteren Entscheidung.
So, ich würde sagen.
Wir haben jetzt lange genug gepodcastet und die letzten beiden Kurzmeldungen nehmen wir einfach mit in die nächste Sendung.
Auf jeden Fall ist alles nicht so wichtig. Und da würden wir uns auch wieder nur wiederholen und wiederholen und wiederholen und das machen wir so ungern. Dann leiten wir da einfach ein Ende ein, welches Ende schwebt dir denn so vor.
Mir schwebt natürlich das Ende mit einem freundlichen Dank vor. Äh und zwar mit ganz besonderem Dank an Markus.
Und besonderem Dank an Susanne, Franz und Hans. Und natürlich Dank an Nils, Nora, Sascha, Lukas, Tobias und Christian.
Bin da teilweise doch sehr überrascht, wie viel.
Begeisterung wir bei den Leuten mit unseren Systemkonformen, mit unserem unkritischen System konformen Geschwur hervorrufen.
Angepasst sind wir einfach. Das ist das Problem.
Angepasst, weich gespült, sind.
Ich auch nicht, aber es wird einem trotzdem vorgeworfen.
Ja, das aber da deswegen machen wir also wenn euch die Folge alt vorkommt, guckt einfach mal, ob inzwischen eine neue gibt.
Genau. Das ist äh eine einfache Lösung. Wir haben immer wieder was zu liefern.
Machen wir auch nächste Woche voraussichtlich.
Wie das nicht aufhört, ne?
Ja, es ist äh schlimm. Dreihundertfünfzig. Die hat schon einundfünfzig. Einfach so.
Nächste Woche, nächste Woche wahrscheinlich wieder mit Thomas. Auch mal ein bisschen mehr. Ist ja nicht so, als gäb's nur in Deutschland schlechte Nachrichten. Gibt auch in Europa und Österreich schlechte Nachrichten.
Sag mal, wie lange, wie lange sind wir jetzt schon? Also ich meine, nicht heute, sondern wenn ich wieder irgendwie.
Wir müssen bald mal wieder ein Jubiläum haben. Wir haben irgendwann im September.
Toba, Oktober. Oktober zwanzig elf. Dann sind das dann neun Jahre.
Das Camp da. Ich hatte in meinem Kopf, dass wir zwanzig, dreißig, das war zwanzig, elf. Naja, wenn wir Glück haben, können wir Zehnjährige wieder mit Publikum feiern.
Ja, könnte passieren.
Mit oder ohne App zwang.
Ja, genau. Genau. So besteht nur Podcast äh Zwang, ne? Also, Leute, schaltet auch nächste Woche wieder rein. Ihr wisst schon, wir sehen uns und hören uns. Bis dann. Tschüss.
Ciao ciao.